this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the do it all website that lets you make
your own website seriously take it from
me if you have your own brand or
business or even just credentials that
you'd like to Fashion into a high
quality resume then making a website
should be something that you're
seriously considering and Squarespace is
by far the easiest and most convenient
way to build a website of your very own
and if you just thought in your head
yeah that's cool but I have no idea how
to design a website then one I heard you
I can read your thoughts and two you
don't have to worry about that one bit
because Squarespace has a gazillion
templates for you to choose or work off
of and after you've got your
beautiful.com if you create online
content you can use squarespace's
fantastic member areas to gain and
reward your supporters or host your own
videos on your own platform or use your
site to link all of your social media
accounts together which is what I'm
doing and why I now just feature my
Squarespace website on my Twitter so hey
if you've ever considered a website
check out squarespace.com for a free
trial and if you want to keep it boom go
to squarespace.com Bandit for 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain you're welcome and now on to the
video you know what's kind of annoying
having to go through multiple videos in
order to get the full story behind
something since we've already gotten
through the bossler of each and every 3D
Zelda boss which is crazy to think about
and inspired by my good friend Hyrule
gamer who just uploaded a similar type
of compilation I have decided to compile
every boss lore video that I've made up
until now into one giant convenient
video for you to either watch the first
time the second time or easily share
with friends should the subject of Zelda
lore ever come up and uh take it from me
if you have a friendship that discusses
video game lore that's a good friendship
you should keep it oh and I have one
favor to ask of you if you're listening
to my voice right now and are able to
leave a comment on the video let me know
what video game or game franchise you'd
like to see get the old boss and dungeon
lore explanation treatment on the
channel I will be reviewing each
suggestion carefully and just so you
know I have full plans on covering the
Metroid franchise soon anyway there's
not much more to say before delving into
the video other than please consider
liking the video if you like the bosses
of The Legend of Zelda and make sure
you're subscribed if you're not all
ready to stick around for more gaming
lore oh and spoiler alert for the entire
series obviously a Zelda game without
bosses is like rice without any Curry
like yeah you could just eat the rice it
might even taste good fried or with a
little salt but where's the doll where's
the paneer where's the chicken tikka the
first genre or grouping of bosses will
cover would be those that are the
natural enemies of the game what I mean
by that is bosses or beings that may
have not been affected by demise's
malice or girham's personality or at
least the ones that are not confirmed to
have been affected speaking of enemies
that aren't confirmed to be affected
there are a few bosses that fit this
criteria that aren't really bosses but
do serve as mini bosses the first time
they're encountered due to the fact that
they are a bit tougher than your average
picoblin which is a trend that happens
with these same enemies and a lot of
Zelda games actually first up is the Liz
alfos which is a monster that may or may
not have been entirely created out of
the evil power and Malice of demise many
years ago when he initially created his
armies to battle against hylia and the
forces of light light the reason I say
they may have been created by demise is
because Phi tells us directly that
demise is the source of all monsters
however there are some monsters which
I'll go over that didn't stem from
demise so it's also possible that things
like the Liz all foes are naturally
occurring species in the land of Hyrule
but I digress the next boss that may
have not originated from demise's power
is the moldarak which is a giant
armor-clad thousand-year-old scorpion
monster with a large singular eye well
actually three eyes with two in its
claws and one in the middle which is
reminiscent of Goma which is another
reappearing boss of the Zelda franchise
that appears differently each time but
every time being some sort of an
arachnid monster that always features a
singular main eye for link to normally
shoot at the mold Iraq is actually just
an aged version of the much more
abundant and much more Tiny araka
Monsters which are very similar to just
real life scorpions with one eye we
don't have any specific reason to
believe these monsters were created by
demise except for the fact that they
disappear in a puff of purple smoke when
they die but you know it could go either
way next up is a boss that would
actually be difficult to connect to
demise and that is the 100 robotic
artificial life form known as the
ld-002g servo or as I like to call him
yarg the robot pirate beep boop Servo is
a member of the ancient robot race
encountered on the sand ship which used
to be just a regular ship before the sea
became sand also fun fact the LD in all
these robots names stands for linero
Desert which makes sense until you
remember that when they were created it
was an ocean not a desert but we just
won't dwell on that for too long we
actually know a little bit about servo's
backstory too according to a single word
from fee it's possible that Servo used
to be a member of the crew of the ship
led by
ld-301n Skipper and that server then led
a few other crew members in a mutiny
against Skipper and his loyal crew but I
know what you're thinking how could
robots command to ship an even Mutiny
against each other where do they come
from well and this is just a theory of
course but in my opinion the ancient
robots were created by an ancient race
of people that are closely associated
with hylia and nehru and technology and
also the color blue you know the Chica
we know they existed in the ancient
times of Skyward Sword because impa
comes from the past I think it's pretty
plausible that the sheikah were mining
time shift stones in order to create the
Gate of time under order of the goddess
hylia who is credited with the creation
of the Gate of time and also possibly
being the goddess of time itself but hey
that's a whole other Theory the time
shift stones that are cut and processed
even have an ancient version of the
shika eye symbol present on them I think
that the ancient robots were most likely
created either by the Chica or by hylia
herself in order to assist in mining
time shift Stones perhaps even in order
to find all of the powerful resource
there is to find in the world before it
can fall into the clutches of demise
because if demise were to also harness
the ability to travel through time at
will that could be problematic this is
why the ancient robots created ancient
ships in the shipyard in order to travel
far across the ancient sea and scour the
region for time shift or led by one
ld-301 model in particular skipper then
one day there was a sea Squall and
conveniently that was also the day that
Servo decided to mute knee and take over
this ship there's also an improved
version of the
ld-002g servo known as The
ld-003d Dread fuse who appears much
later in the game in the sky keep which
is a Shifty dungeon created by hylia in
order to keep the Triforce hidden from
the world and also helps to prove that
the ancient robots were in fact created
by hylia either directly or indirectly
since everything inside the sky keep
must have been placed thereby highly as
a test for the hero this is also another
reason to potentially believe that not
all monsters were created by demise
since there are the goblins and moblins
and keys and others located inside the
key but anyway moving on the next boss
in the section would be the underground
crawling insects known as mole dorms
that make multiple appearances in this
game and in other games in the franchise
I personally believe that these monsters
are just naturally occurring large
insect Wildlife that just so happens to
be aggressive towards link just like
most of their other appearances their
Elon elongated segmented worm-like
centipede-like monsters that are clad in
armor everywhere but for their tails
except for in Twilight Princess when
they're just little jumpy worms the
final boss for this first section of the
video would be the infamously
intimidating Abyssal Leviathan known as
tentalis I had to research long and hard
to get the backs around this one but I'm
pretty sure you're gonna enjoy it you
see long ago in a galaxy far far away
there was a little one-eyed monster
known as Michael Wazowski over a long
painstaking ordeal Mike was finally able
to marry his longtime girlfriend Celia
May together they had a child that
shared characteristics from both of them
and was born with a single iron
snake-like hair tendrils
um in all seriousness though this boss
out of pretty much every Zelda boss in
the history of Zelda bosses is probably
one of the worst designs for an Abyssal
Leviathan that I've ever seen and yes
its design looks like something out of
Monsters Incorporated you're really
similar in fact like like seriously does
Disney know about this do they need to
get involved but appearances aside there
are a couple things that we can guess
about its background which otherwise is
completely devoid of any and all details
see when you actually face the giant
tentacle monster it's in the distant
past as proven by all the water around
the boat and also the fact that the boat
doesn't look like a piece of garbage and
also when you talk to your flying blue
computer companion about tentalis she
confirms that it was a tyrant of the
ancient Seas now this is particularly
interesting because we also know that
where tintalus is a storm or sea Squall
is sure to follow as proven by the storm
or sea Squall that we can see here while
fighting it and while we don't have any
other confirmed records of an ancient
sea monster plaguing anybody in the game
we do have a record of an ancient
terrible sea Squall that happened on the
same day that the Mutiny occurred aboard
Skipper's ship and personally I don't
find that a coincidence so on the one
hand it could be that demise or girohim
was responsible for creating tintalus
and making tintalus make storms that led
to mutinies or on the other hand it
could be that the Fearsome pirate Servo
and his scurvy Robo crew found some way
to call upon the Abyssal Leviathan to
Aid them in the their quest for Mutiny I
think I like that explanation better
because it gives some mythological feel
to Talus and makes the relationship
between it and Servo seem kind of like
the one between the Kraken and Davey
Jones what can I say I love Pirates of
the Caribbean and Tantalus is pretty
cracking like you've gotta admit but
whether tintelus was simply a mysterious
mythological monster of the deep from
ancient times that was called upon by
scurvy Pirates or it was created by
demise is up to you to believe of course
but one other detail I'll point out that
could be nothing but could also mean
something is that tintalus's English
name you know tentalis is extremely
similar to Tantalus which is a Greek
mythological figure one of Zeus's many
children that was famously punished by
being made to stand in a pool of water
that he could not drink out of with an
apple hanging from a tree above him that
he could not eat because it was just Out
Of Reach that's actually where our
modern word tantalize or tantalizing
comes from how that relates to Tantalus
I'm not sure but do with that
information what you will who knows
maybe tintalus wasn't always an Abyssal
sea monster but was cursed into that
form long ago as a punishment moving on
to the next segment of the video it's
time to talk about the many bosses that
were definitely created or influenced by
the dark powers of demise and Co the
most obvious ones would be the stealthos
enemies or the more powerful stall
Master variants which are of course
risen Undead skeletal monsters that were
at one point Warriors in life they're
also one of the only monsters in the
entire franchise that has made an
appearance in every Zelda game I think
I'm not sure I scripted that off the top
of my head is somebody watching fact
check that for me but I'm pretty sure
they've been in every Zelda game anyway
their explanation is the same as always
which is that they are corpses quickened
Once More by demise next up we've got
the main boss Caldera the pyroclastic
fiend from the Earth Temple you know
that Bolder looking living glob of lava
that uses a bunch of rock as armor
fortunately for us we've got a pretty
direct confirmation from girohim himself
that scaldera was more than likely a
demon created by girihim he knows about
scaldera he even introduces link to
scaldera who he calls his friend what a
hospitable guy I guess I'll have to
refer to skull aldira as the pyroclastic
friend from now on next up we've got the
one the only the terrifying ancient
automaton kaloctos located deep within
the Ancient Cistern now besides girohim
or demise himself colloctos is
undoubtedly one of the most recognizable
bosses in all of Zelda history I mean
just look at this thing it's shiny it's
kind of creepy it's got six arms and wee
little eggs I mean what's not to love as
its name insinuates and in conjunction
with the Ancient Cistern within which it
is located colloctos is in fact ancient
and given that it was an automaton that
was ultimately tasked with guarding the
Chamber of the flame I'm pretty sure
hylia who apparently had an act for
making robots was the one to create both
the dungeon itself and colloctos that
being said galactos might have actually
been a sentient machine once much like
the LD models if it weren't for
girihim's interference and the
corruption of demise's malice that's
right you heard me
m-a-l-i-c-e the same stuff that's
swirling around in breath of the wild
that goes by the name Calamity again and
you may have heard of it I'm mean the
pieces add up it came from Ghirahim
which came from demise and it's a dark
purple goopy substance that possesses
and corrupts technology and it's
probably the same substance that's
dropped by the cursed by goblins which
are also present in the dungeon which is
Monster Mel is referred to as an evil
Crystal when it crystallizes Faron also
states that the cistern used to not have
any monsters inside so this means that
once demise or maybe girohim got word of
Link obtaining the goddess sword girohim
took it upon himself to leak malice into
the dungeon personally but what is this
a lore of the dungeons video
no no it's not so we're gonna move on
next up is the dark lizalfos which just
like their name sounds are the dark
versions of regular lesolfos these dark
Liz olfos are two Liz alfo's what cursed
the coblins are tubacablins well kind of
because they don't look like zombies but
they can curse link just like cursed by
Goblin bites do they don't drop evil
crystals as loot but the fact that other
enemies in the game that can also
inflict curse like the cursed bakoblins
or dark keys do drop evil crystals leads
me to believe that the ability to curse
at least in Skyward Sword comes directly
from being possessed by demise's malice
as proven by the evil crystals so in a
nutshell dark Liz all foes are more than
likely malice tainted lizel foes next up
but also in the same dungeon that the
dark lizzle foes are first encountered
are the multiple appearing lava hand
monsters known as magmonosis and to be
honest with you there's literally
nothing about their origins in the game
so logically I feel that just like
girihim was able to create a living lava
demon monster known as Caldera the
pyroclastic friend he probably was also
able to create these living lava demon
hand monsters who knows maybe scaldera
and the magminosis are not only a cool
band name but also the result of malice
being conjoined with the lava of Death
Mountain I mean Eldon volcano something
we may be seeing happen again in tears
of the kingdom and speaking of malice
the final boss to cover before covering
the big baddies themselves would be the
easily forgettable bilocyte which is the
parasite responsible for corrupting
levias or leviath or however you
pronounce his name the wind fish and
also for causing his temporary insanity
bilocyte is malice plain and simple
seriously just look at this concept art
for levias dark reddish purple clouds
corruption sentient eyeballs yeah that
literally fits the bill for exactly what
malice is in breath of the wild the only
question I have is when did levias get
corrupted if he stayed flying up above
the cloud barrier then he should have
been largely unaffected by any of the
Badness happening on the surface right
well as we see in the Leviathan bones of
breath of the Wild and the ending
cutscene for Link's Awakening wind
fishes can definitely descend down to
the surface at will and in Skyward Sword
we even see leviath flying back up to
the sky from beneath the cloud barrier
and there's only one thing down there
the surface so it's possible that
girohim started messing with the
Thunderdome turning it into a
Thunderdome and leviath then flew down
to the surface to check out what the
heck was going on and subsequently got
corrupted by malice somehow he never
actually sheds light on what happened
the personally I'm of the opinion that
it was in fact girohim's doing seriously
when in doubt blamed demise's Uber
powerful super demon running around the
world with the express purpose of
setting everything as out of order as
possible and what a masterful segue into
talking about the fabulous boy himself
in the final segment of this video but
right before we do explain Mr eyeshadow
I wanted to thank you for watching these
videos seriously I know it doesn't
really matter to the vast majority
watching right now but it means a lot to
me if this isn't the first one of these
videos of mine you've watched or if you
enjoy this one being your first one so
far by the way hi my name is Bandit nice
to meet you I wanted to ask if you would
be so kind as to consider subscribing to
the channel I know lots of you are
either rolling your eyes or looking to
fast forward the segment right now and
that's okay but for those of you still
listening I just wanted you to know that
for the first time I'm beginning to feel
like this channel could really grow like
really really grow especially with this
lore of the bosses series expanding into
other franchises and I can see that 80
of my viewers are about 4 out of every
five people watching my videos currently
are actually not subscribed to the
channel to put that into perspective if
that were flipped and it was actually 80
of you that are subscribed then this
channel would literally be at over 1
million subscribers since starting the
lore of the bosses series which is
insane to think about but anyway I won't
take up any more runtime talking about
this once again thank you so much for
watching and please consider subscribing
to help grow the channel and flip that
statistic to help get us to let's say
300 000. dream big right and you can
always unsubscribe later if I lose my
touch and now back to girohim and really
it's kind of hard to explain girihim's
existence without also explaining
demises but in either case let's start
with what we know about girohim we know
that he's a Demon Lord being one of the
most powerful versions of monsters in
the entire franchise who proclaims
himself to be the lord of the surface
and that he was created by demise in
order to be an extension of his will and
carry on the battle against hylia no
matter how many years it might take
which is exactly parallel to five who
was created by Hailey in order to be an
extension of her will and carry on the
battle against demise no matter how many
years that might take but more on the
parallelism between these two parties
and just a bit he's also very confident
and driven and cunning able to thwart
even a wish of the Triforce but none of
that is crucial information to be honest
girihim really isn't that hard to
explain he was created by demise he
serves demise case closed the real
mystery is why is everything regarding
girohim and demise strangely exactly
parallel to hylia and her partner well
I'll tell you what I think but
forewarning we are entering the major
Theory zone of course you are as always
welcome to leave whatever you personally
would like to I'd like to start off by
saying that there are many different
theories about how demise came from
Laurel and stuff like that and it's all
really good stuff ultimately as far as I
can tell it comes down to the fact that
demise is said to have emerged from a
fissure or crack within the Earth and
his master sword AKA girohim in sword
form has an inverted Triforce symbol in
the exact place where the highly a
master sword has an upright one the
fissure that he emerged from is similar
to the fissures that connect Laurel and
Hyrule in A Link Between Worlds and the
inverted Triforce symbol is seemingly
the same as the inverted Triforce symbol
also from low rule which was a land
destroyed long ago this theory
insinuates that that might even be the
entire reasoning for demise invading
Hyrule so that he could have hyrule's
Triforce instead like I said this is
actually a really good theory and really
great way of thinking but it does leave
a few things up to the imagination for
instance it doesn't explain where demise
came from as in literally where or
rather who he came from it also doesn't
explain his intentions as in why he
wants a Triforce in the first place or
why he hates you know good my theory
will explain both in the beginning the
goddesses created everything every ocean
Every Mountain Every Creature down to
every last blade of grass and this isn't
debatable this is canonical proven lore
that even has its own cut scenes in
Ocarina of Time in Twilight Princess and
once the goddesses were finished with
their creation they left the world and
at the point of their departure the
Triforce was made however that was not
all that was created now I'd like to ask
you something something that's very
philosophical but also a cold reality
given that the world of Hyrule was
created that would mean that nothing
existed before it right meaning light
and dark heat and cold up and down and
good and evil and all these contrasting
forces of the universe that give it form
did not exist yet when the world was
created all of these things came to
fruition out of the creation of contrast
because in each case one cannot exist
without the other light was created
therefore dark was subsequently created
as well heat was created therefore cold
was as well up was created therefore
down was as well and good was created
therefore evil must have been created as
well and this is the Crux of my theory
what if the concepts of Good and Evil
which must have been created along with
the creation of everything were actually
literally manifested in the beings known
as hylia the goddess and demise the
demon twin deities of Good and Evil to
govern the world and Define life and
progress think about it where else would
demise have come from if not from the
same origin of literally everything else
in the universe and given that
everything that is good in the entire
franchise somehow stems from hylia and
every thing that's evil in the entire
franchise somehow stems from demise and
both of these individuals are
inexplicably all-powerful with permanent
Eternal effects on the world wouldn't it
make sense for both of them to literally
be the embodiments of Good and Evil
incarnate I mean the more you think
about it the more it actually makes
sense everything about them is perfectly
parallel to one another hylia defends
the Triforce demise pursues it hylia
created a master sword with a Triforce
facing Skyward demise created a master
sword with a Triforce facing towards the
Earth highly exists at the Edge of Time
demise has conquered time itself do you
see a pattern because it's actually
everywhere and we know the goddesses
themselves are morally neutral I mean
they have to be right plus we've seen
them time and time again make very
morally gray choices such as the
repeated choosing of Ganondorf to host
the Triforce of power or the flooding of
Hyrule player or the flooding of Hyrule
prior to Wind Waker you know not
everyone made it out alive of that one
mountaintops are only so big so in my
opinion this works perfectly because the
goddesses themselves are outside side of
our ideologies of Good and Evil because
they created it but okay you're probably
thinking right about now yeah that's
logical and philosophical and everything
and it does explain exactly where demise
came from but what about his rage his
hatred that never perishes where did
that come from and that is a great
question because seriously what happened
to demise to make him so eternally
hateful of the goddesses in hylia well
here's a simple kind of paradoxical
answer for you what if he's simply
self-aware demise isn't stupid actually
quite the opposite he's brilliant and so
masterful a tactician that he
successfully plotted his own escape from
his imprisoned form before he was even
imprisoned by creating girohim so what
if demise is so hateful of the goddesses
because he knows why they created him
and he didn't ask to be made he didn't
ask for this life of pain and I know
that's a really dark concept but
seriously what if you found out one day
that you were created for the sole
purpose of being the Incarnation of evil
in the world you were never destined for
a nice or good or happy ending unlike
your twin High instead you had only
bitterness and defeat to look forward to
as ordained by your creators so you let
your anger at your own existence
overcome you and become your every
thought not knowing that in your blind
rage and Defiance of your creators and
your twin you were becoming exactly what
they had intended you would become
hatred itself an eternal curse upon good
and a necessary Force to drive life into
death into life into death into life
again all in an eternal cycle because
without contrast we don't have color
without Darkness we don't have light and
without a necessary evil we don't have
good and that is my explanation for why
demise or more specifically the bringer
of demise as is his real name in
Japanese was created a Zelda game
without bosses is like a bowl of ramen
with only noodles it's like yeah it's a
bowl those are ramen noodles but where's
the flavor where's the succulent meat
where's those little swirly looking
things that are sometimes making
appearances in the bowl let's begin with
the very first set of bosses in the game
Queen Goma King dadongo and baronade all
three of these bosses were the direct
result of Ganondorf throwing a fit
because nobody would give him the
spiritual Stones first he wanted the
Kokiri Emerald from the Deku Tree and
when the Great Deku Tree refused
Ganondorf cursed it with a literal giant
spider monster known as the armored
parasite Goma in order to sap the tree
of its power and literally kill it which
he succeeds at actually now Ganondorf
himself is a powerful sorcerer capable
of Performing great acts of dark magic
so this means that Goma originated from
one of two places either one gomu was
created out of thin air by Ganondorf to
curse and sap the Deku Tree or two
Ganondorf used his dark powers to evolve
a normal spider into the humongous
monster Goma although this doesn't
really matter much in the grand scheme
of things and can be left up to personal
interpretation because the end result is
the same next up we have the boss of the
dongo's cavern King dedongo similarly to
Goma kingdadango was heavily implied to
be the result of a curse from Ganondorf
according to the leader of the Goron's
daruna Gander also asked him for the
Goron's Ruby but was once again denied
the spiritual Stone prompting the desert
king to fill the cavern with quote
ancient creatures and seal it shut with
a giant boulder in the entrance
preventing the gorons from accessing the
Finger Licking Good rocks inside now
given that the dongo's cavern had no
dudangos in it before ganondorf's curse
and given that these ancient creatures
that darunia is talking about are in
fact the dongos and King dadongo himself
this means that tadango's Cavern once
had to dongos in it hence its name
possibly even one as big as the skull
present in the dungeon but they were all
cleared out Long Ago by ancient gorons
or rather by an ancient heroic Goron in
particular but more on that later this
means that Ganondorf must have
resurrected that Adam goes from their
ancient tombs and by extension King
dadongo himself with dark magic in order
to punish the gorans for not giving him
the stone King dadongo had a short
second lifespan though next we have the
anemone anemone baronade which was
responsible for putting jabu-jabu in
such a bad mood once again this seems to
be the direct result of ganondorf's
curse since King Zora confirms that
jabba jabba was different and sickly
following ganondorf's visit the Gerudo
likely asked about the spiritual Stone
and was given an unsatisfying answer
since the stone was actually in
possession of the Zora Princess Ruto and
similarly to Goma baronade leeched the
life of jabu-jabu parasitically and
might have even killed jabu-jabu if it
wasn't for the big fish literally
swallowing the hero of time points to
link for being a more effective
painkiller than Ibuprofen now it's time
to grow up after link turns into an
adult seven years have passed and once
again Ganondorf has been running around
setting bosses in places they shouldn't
be this is again true of the first
second and third temples which feature
Phantom Ganon volvagia the dragon and
the water tentacle monster morpha
Phantom Ganon was an apparition created
by Ganondorf for the purposes of
stopping link from saving Seria from the
curse of the Forest Temple which
awakened her as a sage however it should
be noted that Ganondorf knowingly made
his doppelganger ghost a bit less
powerful than he himself is possibly
because he knew from the get-go that he
would need to let link live in order to
come into the castle himself and reveal
the Triforce of Courage but that
speculative volvagia was another case of
the Dead being brought back to life by
the hand of Ganondorf and like I
mentioned earlier volvagia himself was
actually slain Long Ago by agoron Hero
using the fabled Megaton Hammer
according to link that not this link the
Goron named afterlink known as link
anyway volvagia was a dragon that lived
inside Death Mountain as its protector
spirit and is even said to be the
ancestor of velu the protector Spirit of
dragon Roost Mountain allegedly he was
always rather aggressive and as such the
ancient Goron hero saw fit to smash him
to Smithereens with a giant hammer and
once Ganondorf became ruler of the land
he decided he would make a spectacle of
the gorons and feed them one by one as
snacks to the freshly revived volvagia
in order to scare the other hyrulean
races into Obedience of course link has
something to say about this the final
boss that Ganondorf is solely
responsible for creating would be the
very strange aquatic amoeba morpha which
Ganondorf placed inside the water temple
in order to both free zor's domain and
its inhabitants and drain Lake hylia of
its water whenever given an explicit
reason as to why Ganondorf so royally
screwed over the Zora people but it can
be assumed that it was in order to Halt
the progress of the water Sage's
Awakening now with ganondorf's many
Creations out of the way let's move on
to the bosses that have their own reason
for being you know bosses back in the
Forest Temple there's a group of Poe
sisters that haunts the area known as
the poe sisters these ghostly girls
don't have an explained backstory
present anywhere in the game but it can
be assumed that their Spirits have been
bound to the Forest Temple for quite
some time since there are portraits of
the ghosts located within its
castle-like walls it's also interesting
to note that each of the girls Joe Beth
Amy and Meg are named after the four
sisters from the novel Little Women this
implies that they weren't created as
pose but were once actually living
people and since Poes are heavily
implied to be evil spirits regardless of
their once peaceful Natures who are
Tethered to the living world because of
some unresolved attachment we can also
assume that the girls were probably all
murdered in this Temple before their
natural death deaths and may have
actually been friendly when they were
alive next up let's take a look at the
infamous miniboss of the water temple
Dark Link dark link is without a doubt
probably the most popular Zelda enemy
other than Ganondorf himself and for
good reason evil doppelganger types are
always popular enemies across all kinds
of media since it's a great question
that Navi also raises in the game how
exactly are you supposed to conquer
yourself is that even possible from a
philosophical standpoint regardless I'd
like to point out that one thing that
people confuse a lot is the identity of
Dark Link shown here with that of Link's
Shadow from a link to the past or the
shadow links from other games simply put
those other inverted link enemies that
look similar are actually completely
different in both their Origins and
their purposes now keep in mind that
there are many different Dark Link
origin theories out there for Ocarina of
Time some of which are very good that
you are more than welcome to believe if
you so desire but I'm going to explain
what I think his origin story is from a
very realistic and somewhat boring point
of view which will differ from several
of those Series this darkling can
occurring of time which is where the
name darkling comes from was most likely
placed here indirectly by whoever made
the temple in the first place see the
water temple was created as a place
where the Zora could worship the water
spirits but it's also clear that it was
designed to be a trial as well what
trials in Zelda games unheard of but
it's true because unlike the other
temples where it's more or less about
link finding his way to the end of
whatever structure he's in the water
temple specifically shows you the end
right off the bat and instead requires
intelligent manipulation of water levels
and going back and forth between its
many rooms and hidden compartments in
order to solve its Grand puzzle and
access the final area just outside of
your reach and perhaps the solution of
the temple is in and of itself how the
Zora worship the water spirits that
being said this also means that the room
in which we Face Dark Link was created
as part of this big trial along with the
room's mechanics this room is illusory
it creates false images that make you
think it has no wall and that the floor
is covered by a very reflective surface
of water emphasis on reflective which is
the point of this particular trial it's
my interpretation that the purpose of
this room is to test the worshiper
traversing through the water temple with
a challenge of Conquering the reflective
Darkness within themselves in order to
purify themselves for the water Spirits
after all Navi doesn't imply that Dark
Link is its own entity like she does
with every other monster in the game if
anything she acts like Dark Link is just
an extension of Link himself and since
Dark Link appears to originate from the
tree in the middle of the room and
reflects Link's appearance and moveset
it's my personal interpretation that the
fruit of the tree if you will is a
watery reflection of the individual who
would Brave the trials of the temple in
order to seek purification from its
Waters this is why Dark Link exists and
is a boss at least an Ocarina of Time
number next we have the mini boss of the
Shadow Temple and boss of the area
beneath the well and subject of many
nightmares the Dead Hand now previously
the Dead Hand and the Shadow Temple
itself were hugely speculated over but
ever since the release of the Hyrule
encyclopedia we've gotten a confirmed
answer as to where the spooky Temple
came from it was built as a place for
the sheikah to capture and torture the
enemies of the royal family which would
explain the you know torture devices and
cages it marks such a Dark and Bloody
time for the history of Hyrule that the
royal family is actually forbidden to
even speak of it of course there are
many other Mysteries present in the
temple but that's another video for
another day dead hands presence in this
old chica Temple can only be due to one
of two things either one the Dead Hand
is the result of dark sheikah
experiments in order to create some sort
of hungry Undead man-eating monster with
which to feed their subjects too to get
rid of them after they were done
torturing them for information
explaining the dead hand chamber and
many human bones present in it or two
the Dead Hand was supernaturally created
from the aforementioned many corpses
that lie in the Shadow Temple walls when
the dark power of Bongo Bongo was
released and added to the temple cursing
it and giving rise to the undead within
this would explain and why the Dead Hand
initially pops up underneath the well
and its dead appearance with the bleach
white blood-stained skin and its human
skull head it would also explain the
ability for Dead Hand to summon infinite
numbers of hands to grab hold of its
victims with though I personally favor
the first explanation due to the fact
that there are two dead hands in the
game and playing pretty heavily that
they were purposefully created and
placed in chica torture chambers and
speaking of the Shadow Temple its final
boss Bongo Bongo is also shrouded in
mystery for those who don't know Bongo
Bongo is an evil spirit whose appearance
is similar to that of a hanging beheaded
man with a giant eye in its neck and cut
off hands that just can't help but play
the drums Bongo Bunga was sealed within
the well by the shika leader impa but
broke out when the darkness grew too
powerful and this is most likely because
of the rise of ganondorf's power since
he is in fact the leader of the forces
of evil where Bongo Bongo came from
initially though is again widely
speculated over but I have a more
realistic take on its origin many people
assume that the man whose house used to
be located where the well sits now is
the real identity of Bongo Bongo and
this may or may not be true one thing's
for certain though and that is that
Bongo Bongo is a spirit a big Spirit not
to be overly simplistic but we do see
what spirits of the Dead look like as
far as size is concerned in the game
their pose and they almost always end up
being smaller or thinner than the
average human but in some cases we come
across pose that are far bigger than the
others called Big pose and one of the
biggest pose in particular is the boss
named jalhala from the Wind Waker
jalhala is so massive because he's
composed of other smaller pose so here's
the question what if Bongo Bongo the
evil Shadow Spirit is such a massive
entity because he's composed of the
spirits of many dead people and you know
where a bunch of dead people were made
in the middle of kakariko under the well
and within the Shadow Temple
conveniently where Bongo Bongo
originated from my personal
interpretation is that the dead hands
killed so many people that their
combined lingering hateful Spirits
manifested as the Phantom shower the
Phantom Shadow Beast Bongo Bongo whose
hands were cut off due to the spirits of
the Dead being Shackled in life and
whose head was cut off to signify their
executions moving on to the next Temple
the spirit Temple dedicated to the sand
goddess located within the Gerudo desert
also The Hideout for Ganondorf and his
followers before he rose to power and
moved to the floating Hyrule Castle the
mini bosses of the temple are the iron
Knuckles which have a pretty simple
explanation they're brainwashed Garuda
women in suits of heavy armor swinging
massive weapons and honestly I don't
have a problem believing that they could
physically do that because have you seen
their biceps but the bigger question is
who is responsible for brainwashing
these poor women well that would be the
boss bosses of the temple the twin witch
sisters known separately as kotake and
kaume or together as twin rova according
to the lore twin rova is ganondorf's
surrogate mother slash mothers and since
there's actually two of them and their
sisters I personally feel like the term
surrogate mother used here actually
means more like adopt mothers rather
than the other meaning of a surrogate
mother which includes a woman birthing a
child for another woman who can't that
being said it makes sense then that twin
rova would be such a devout follower of
Ganondorf they're just proud to see
their little boy grow up to be the evil
King he was always meant to be what a
cutie they're also both over 400 years
old and apparently go to heaven when
they die huh they must have helped other
old ladies across the street when they
were alive the final boss of this game
is none other than Ganondorf himself who
transforms into Ganon after his initial
defeat most people know ganondorf's
backstory even if they haven't played
Ocarina of Time but I'll go over it
anyway Ganondorf was the last known male
Gerudo born to the Gerudo race that's
historically been entirely female well
mostly female it was said that once
every hundred years a boy would be born
and that boy would be the Gerudo King
which is why Ganondorf is the last
Gerudo King however since he kind of
tried to end the world ever since
ganondorf's defeat at the end of Ocarina
of Time and Wind Waker and Twilight
Princess and a link to the past the
Gerudo women have completely sworn off
men even those of their own race and as
such they are now for all intents and
purposes entirely composed of women if
there have been male Garuda born since
the time of Ganondorf it has been
undocumented and unconfirmed and they
have been banished from their own
Homeland which is why their existence
these days is a theory a believable
Theory but a theory nonetheless but back
to Ganondorf in Wind Waker we're able to
get a better understanding of why
Ganondorf did what he did in regards to
overthrowing the Hylian royal family he
was jealous the Gerudo desert is a harsh
environment and ultimately as the Gerudo
King he wanted the lands or Winds of
Hyrule to be the new home for his people
which seems Noble but he absolutely went
about it the wrong way and somewhere
along the way lost sight of his
Democratic Ambitions and instead began
to covet the ultimate power known as the
Triforce in order to subjugate the
entire world to his will forcefully
initially Ganondorf swears allegiance to
the king of Hyrule in order to craftily
locate the Triforce for himself but
celaduses through his lies and asks link
to help her with getting rid of the man
with the evil eyes since you know you
can't account on the king of Hyrule to
do something like that after Link and
Zelda opened the door of time to find
the master sword and thus the entrance
to the sacred realm Ganondorf actually
predicted that they would do this and
gains free access to the Triforce within
the sacred realm and attempts to take it
for himself however due to the imbalance
within his own heart the Triforce splits
into its three separate pieces of power
wisdom and courage each then residing
within Ganondorf Zelda and Link
respectively as they represented those
individual attributes the most after
this happened Ganondorf wanted to find
the other two pieces to reform the
completed Triforce and thus regain
ultimate power but with Zelda being in
hiding and Link fast asleep for seven
years he had to come up with another
plan in order to locate the missing
pieces and just like Ganondorf had link
do his work for him seven years ago once
again link located Zelda and her
Triforce of wisdom and brought the
Triforce of Courage himself directly to
Ganondorf without the Gerudo usurper
ever having to leave his throne room
which he predicted again of course link
is able to defeat Ganondorf which he he
did not predict who tries to bring the
castle down on top of Lincoln Zelda in
another attempt to kill them when this
fails Ganondorf who I guess was still
not dead calls upon the Triforce of
power to transform into the pig-like
monster known as Ganon who lives for
about 40 seconds since the hero of time
with the blade of evil Spain was
standing like two feet away and proceeds
to kill Ganon immediately who then
reverts back to Ganondorf who then
becomes sealed away temporarily but for
the remainder of this game simply put
Ganon is the demonic form that Ganondorf
transforms into that embodies his lust
for power and as far as the timeline's
concerned this is the very moment that
Ganon was created who just as a reminder
we still haven't been able to rid the
world of to this day I personally
believe that Ganon is the embodiment of
the curse that demise places upon hylia
back in the events of Skyward Sword and
that Ganondorf was able to access this
power through the Triforce of power but
that's just my personal headcanon
ultimately this is all kind of the
goddess's fault since they're the ones
who decided to leave an all-powerful
Relic in the hands of mere mortals
anyway but alas we are not destined to
understand the wind of the Gods a Zelda
game without bosses is like a box of
chocolates that's empty you never know
what you're gonna get because there's
nothing in there the bosses in Majora's
Mask can be pretty much all grouped into
one of three umbrella categories bosses
that were corrupted by the power of the
four giant masks bosses that are the
four giant masks and of course the big
bad Majora itself so let's start with
the first category of bosses that have
their own reasons or were corrupted and
work our way up the ladder the first
bosses you encounter in the game besides
the Skull Kid slash Majora's Mask
themselves which isn't really a boss
fight would be the two mini bosses of
the woodfall temple the first of which
is a dino foes this is simply a monster
that does appear multiple times in the
game and across the franchise that's
really more of a powerful species of
monster than a notable boss so really
the explanation for it is the same as it
would be for a Liz alfos or an air alfos
or even of a goblin it serves the forces
of darkness and somehow either found or
created its own weapon and armor and
wants nothing more than to make link go
to sleep in a permanent kind of way the
next Minnie Mouse of the woodfall temple
is yet another repeating anime be in the
game the gecko with two K's however
unlike the dinofos the gecko is actually
not normally a bloodthirsty monster it's
actually a corrupted frog which is
otherwise harmless and kind of cute when
under the effects of corruption the Frog
mutates into a more lizard-like form
that walks on two legs and you know
tries to kill link and both geckos in
the game this one and the one that
appears later on in the Great Bay Temple
shows signs of intelligence in that the
first one runs away from Lincoln
primarily attacks by riding on top of a
killer Turtle monster called a snapper
and the second one encases itself in Mad
jelly which acts like both a shield and
a method of attacking Link in either
case when defeated the geckos don't die
but rather just devolve back to their
original little frog body so you don't
have to feel too bad about it as far as
what dark power is responsible for
corrupting them though why it would be
none other than Majora itself or more
specifically the corresponding giant
mask but more on that later the next
natural boss encountered would be the
wizrow which is again a repeating
miniboss that pops up in the snowhead
temple and then again in the castle of
ikana Stone Tower Temple and the secret
Shrine most fans probably know that whiz
robes are not new enemies to the
franchise far from it actually with
their first appearance stemming from the
first game and stretching to being
included in 12 of the games in total in
each appearance Wiz robes are always an
intelligent species of humanoid
creatures that are very proficient in
Magic but the Curious Thing about them
is that they tend to switch up their
appearance quite a bit from being more
human looking in the original games to
being birds or maybe even the Rito in
the Wind Waker to being whatever the
hell this is in breath of the wild kinda
looks like Groove from Despicable Me
we're going to steal them all regardless
the wizrobes in Majora's Mask are
definitely more human looking and of
course are set out to make Link's life
as hard as they can they teleport around
their rooms and cast magical attacks
towards link and when defeated burst
into flames leaving no corpse behind as
far as where they come from though it's
about as unclear as any of the other Wiz
robes in the franchise they appear to be
of a race of humanoid creatures that
learned magic and decided to serve the
forces of darkness which in this case
would be Majora and its lackeys I don't
personally think they're completely
human though on account of their rather
large stature and goblin-like appearance
moving on the next bosses are the Gerudo
pirates from the pirate stronghold which
are really just Gerudo women and this is
one of those bosses in Majora's Mask
that's only really explainable by way of
Hyrule encyclopedia's interpretation of
termina which again is to say that
termina was created out of the skull
kid's Twisted memories of Hyrule clearly
the Skull Kid either had heard of the
Gerudo women of the desert or had seen
them before and I'm personally leaning
towards the ladder because iron Knuckles
and even the witch sisters koame and
kotake which are straight out of the
deserts of Ocarina of Time are also
present in Majora's Mask but they all
operate and act completely differently
with no ties to their original lore in
this game the Gerudo aren't desert
dwellers but are rather fearsome Pirates
and without getting into too much of the
narrative they cross paths with link
when link takes it upon himself to save
the eggs of Lulu who is the main singer
of the Super Six Zora rock group called
The indiegogos the Gerudo Pirates under
the leadership of one particular pirate
named Avail stole Lulu's seven baby eggs
because the Skull Kid told them they
were the key to entering the Great Bay
Temple which they wanted to enter in
search of getting rich off of the
treasure within Pirates am I right
anyway that's where the Garuda swords
women as mini bosses come in link fights
three of them in the game Each of which
are guarding one of Lulu's eggs next up
is one of two mini bosses in the Great
Bay Temple a giant eyeball monster known
as wart Ward also appears in the secret
Shrine but there are reasons to believe
that all the bosses in the secret Shrine
are actually duplicate bosses from the
land of termina which would mean that in
reality there's only really one wart on
the old great Hyrule encyclopedia that
used to be an actual online resource
hosted on the official zelda.com but has
since been taken down for unknown
reasons wart was said to have been a
guardian of the Great Bay Temple at one
point it's unknown as to why wart is no
longer considered a guardian of the
Great Bay Temple but since it's a theme
with the game as well as most Zelda
games I'll chalk it up to the corruption
of the Great Bay Temple's corresponding
giant mask next up is the fun stuff the
bosses of ikana and by fun I mean scary
and depressing to start the entire land
of ikana is that of a forgotten and
Barren way Wasteland that was once the
Mighty Kingdom of ikana and became the
location of countless Wars and battles
and bloodshed and just general
unpleasantness it's also currently
experiencing a very particular plague
one that entails the countless dead
soldiers and foreign assassins coming
back to life on the plus side this makes
explaining a large portion of its bosses
easier since said large portion of
bosses in icono Valley are the
aforementioned Undead according to the
undead king of icana named egos dewikana
the undead are all awry and evil and
Restless because someone flung open the
doors of the Stone Tower Temple from
which a dark Wind Blows with all that
being said the first boss you face in
ikana is the undead giant who served in
ikana's Army as its Captain known as
Captain Kita or skolkita who upon being
resurrected immediately challenges you
to a race because he's got the Need for
Speed the captain was actually defeated
in battle which brought him shame that
carried with him into death and is also
the reason why he's dead however upon
being defeated by link he passes his
captain hat on to link and asks you to
give his final words that the war is
over to his men who still Linger on as
tall children in the Mortal realm
serving their Captain even in death and
after he tells link this he asks his
captain if he may take his leave and
finally he takes it following the undead
Trail all the way to the crumbling
castle of ikana link will then meet the
lackeys of the King two unnamed stalfo
Skelly Bros and the King himself in the
throne room upon defeating all of them
and curing their Undead bodies by
burning them with light egos do Icona
explains that the kingdom of ikana is
now fallen due to Petty battles over
ultimately meaningless conflicts the
kind of which was beginning to unfold as
his lackeys began to bicker just moments
before burning away into nothingness he
also explains that the dead began to
rise because of the dark spell
originating from the Stone Tower Temple
and after teaching link the elegy of
emptiness which summons forth a soldier
with no heart and is also the reason why
the Ben Drowned Creepypasta still haunts
fans to this day Burns away himself
asking link to shine the light of
Justice upon his kingdom with his dying
breath this light of Justice comment
also seems to imply that even for the
plague of the undead was a Scourge upon
ikana injustices had already fatally
infected her heart now there are a few
other mini bosses present in ikana but
they're legitimately hard to explain
because technically speaking they
shouldn't exist here such as the iron
Knuckles and the big Poe and the poe
sisters pose themselves exist as
lingering spirits of the dead and are a
staple of the Zelda franchise and in a
land soaked with blood and lined with
countless bodies lingering Spirit seems
to be a given but it's the iron Knuckles
and Poe's sisters specifically that must
have come from the skull kid's memories
especially the latter who are a group of
four sisters that once resided inside of
the Forest Temple of Ocarina of Time
which the Skull Kid lived right outside
of especially given that in the child
timeline which is when this game takes
place link would have never turned into
an adult and killed the poe sisters in
the adult timeline so logically they
should still be located within their
Forest Temple and the same goes for the
iron knuckles in the spirit Temple
however because we're working off of the
assumption that termina is a twisted
version of Hyrule that is somewhat
parallel to it we are going to go with
that explanation for the iron Knuckles
and poses an even sharp and flat present
in Icona Valley the final two bosses of
this first category are the mini bosses
of the Stone Tower Temple itself the
first of which is the gato Master the
strongest and master of the Garo who are
present all over the land of ikana the
Garo are also Undead just like most of
the other monsters in ikana and are
actually spies that hail from a country
that was at war with ikana when it was
alive according to Pamela's father who's
a super smart scientist Professor dude
the Garo may even be Hollow underneath
their robes and one of the reasons to
believe this is that it is Garo law to
destroy their own bodies upon death
leaving no corpse behind something they
still do even in their undeath the fact
that the garam Master is here within the
temple and the fact that the garamaster
knows the secret of flipping the temple
is strange very strange and actually
leads me to believe that the garam
Master may have actually originated from
the temple see egos do ikana says pretty
clearly that it's an impenetrable
stronghold that hundreds of his soldiers
could not topple this implies that it's
not his stronghold not a creation of the
kingdom of ikana and since it does
require some jumping to infiltrate which
the Garo ninjas are all too proficient
at perhaps the Stone Tower actually was
the home of the Garo but that's just a
tiny little mini Theory to explain the
Garo Master the next and final not main
boss of the game would be none other
than the one the only the creepy the
vague Gomez now this Scythe wielding
boss hovers above the ground covers
itself in bats and has a rather crazed
expression on its face and of course is
one of the most unexplained beings in
the history of the Zelda franchise so
that's awesome the aforementioned
zelda.com encyclopedia that's no longer
visible online once said that Gomez was
a powerful vampire which kind of sort of
explains all the bats although whether
or not the old official Zelda website
definition is Canon is debatable either
way though I think that Gomez is most
likely a creation of whoever cursed the
land of ikana by throwing the doors to
the Stone Tower Temple open and here's
why it's because thematically everything
about Gomez is dark Gomez is surrounded
by bats which are nocturnal Predators
Gomez itself is so dark that you can
barely see any detail Tales of its body
other than its eyes and gaping smiling
mouth it also wields a giant reaper-like
Scythe which is to represent death and
also goes hand in hand with darkness and
is the antithesis of light and life and
since iconic kingdom is said to be
enshrouded in darkness that stems from
the Stone Tower Temple it could be that
Gomez himself is the Incarnation of said
darkness in other words Gomez is the
curse that was placed upon ikana the one
that's making the dead come to life but
who made the curse you ask we'll get to
that in a bit but a cool little ass
detail I'll cover about Gomez is that
his name in French is which means the
Grim Reaper and is also the French name
of the death sword from Twilight
Princess both of which are bosses that
wield giant bladed weapons and resemble
the Grim Reaper perhaps their
commonality is that they are both
Bringers of death or rather Bringers of
undeath with all of the minibosses of
the first category of the game out of
the way it's time to start focusing on
the main bosses of the game specifically
the four giant masks that Majora created
in order to capture the four giants of
termina which are the four regarding
deities of the land of termina which was
once a land with only one country and no
divisions or borders let's start off by
briefly covering the story of the Giants
in case anybody doesn't know or needs a
refresher the Giants were not only the
Protectors of termina but were also the
personal Friends of the skull kid
perhaps even his only friends eventually
though the Giants decided they wanted to
sleep I guess and in doing so walked a
hundred steps north south east and west
thus dividing the land into four
quadrants and leaving the skull kid
behind this broke the skull kid's heart
and reportedly he then started to
unleash his anger upon the people of
termina and this is apparently long
before the events of Majora's Mask
eventually the people called out to the
Giants to come to save them from this
naughtiness and they then told the skull
kid to leave termina or they will
literally tear him apart yeesh this
broke the skull kid's heart even more
and then he returned quote to the
heavens where we can only assume he then
met the two fairies in the Lost Woods
and eventually stumbled across the happy
mask salesman and then link and then the
rest is history now remember when I said
at the start of this video there that
we're going with the encyclopedia's
explanation of the creation of termina
well we still are but I also wanted to
state that this history between the
Giants and the Skull Kid seemingly
proves that terminum must have existed
before the Skull Kid dawned Ventura's
mask meaning termina couldn't have been
created by the mask right well yes and
no see I think termina already existed
and that it's a different world that
exists somewhere deep below the land of
Hyrule and it's accessible via a portal
located inside an old tree in the Lost
Woods and no I'm not going to expand on
that because termina isn't the point of
this video I also believe that the Skull
Kid found this world one day and began
going their back and forth out of
curiosity eventually befriending the
four giants before eventually being
banished from there however the Skull
Kid returns to termina after obtaining
the Majora's Mask only this time his
mind has begun to become quite altered
due to the corruption of Majora's power
either this or Majora really did create
terminal when the Skull Kid donned The
Mask it's just that the Skull Kid dawned
The Mask some time ago which I suppose
is possible but unlikely since the happy
mask salesman appears here in the
channel file timeline either way at some
point he gets an idea and that idea is
Revenge on the Giants in the land of
termina itself now I'll get into the
entirety of the Revenge plan more in the
final section covering Majora but as far
as the Giants are concerned basically
the four giant masks were created by the
Skull Kid slash Majora in order to trap
the Giants inside of them transforming
their physical bodies into monsters of
the skull kid's Design One became Odawa
the giant masked jungle Warrior One
became got the giant mechanical goat
monster another became gaorg the giant
fish monster and the last became twin
mold the giant masked insects the
monsters were in my opinion none other
than the Giants themselves who took on
these forms upon their imprisonment kind
of like the imprisoned from Skyward
Sword which is demise's transformation
into a giant avocado with Squishy toes
although it's unknown as to what made
them transform into what they did
specifically since the four giant masks
eventually returned to Majora's side
though I can only assume that the masks
and subsequent monsters were designed
and created by Majora itself once
trapped within the masks the Giants then
became the scourges of the lands they
swore to protect each cursing their own
respective quadrants of termina the
Southern giant became Odawa of the
woodfall temple and cursed the swamp
into becoming toxic the northern giant
became god of the snowhead temple and
cursed the usually warm and balmy
Mountain into a fierce unending blizzard
the Western giant became gaorg of the
Great Bay Temple and plagued the waters
with uneasy murkiness and caused the
weather to become even hotter and the
Eastern giant became twin mold of the
Stone Tower Temple and covered the land
in darkness and undeath their Corruption
of the lands also led to the creation of
several monsters and bosses that we
already discussed such as the geckos or
egos do ikana but at the end of it all
after link frees all the Giants from
their evil mask shackles were left with
one burning question why why did Majora
specifically curse these giants into
these specific monsters it's finally
time to talk about the ones that started
it all Majora and the skull kid and
here's another fair warning buckle your
seatbelts because this is about to get
crazy most fans know by heart the story
of the skull kid a mischievous
child-like Forest imp that Don evil
masked and acted out in probably the
worst temper tantrum the world has ever
seen But the character that really gets
people going is that of Majora where did
it come from is it an it or was it a
person at one point and why is it now
sealed inside a mask let us begin with
what we know according to the happy mask
salesman the Majora's Mask was created
by an ancient tribe who used the mask
for hexing rituals which is another word
for cursing or bewitching so you know
this ancient tribe was definitely not
one of the good ones however that
ancient tribe that used the mask for
cursing others decided themselves that
the mask was too powerful and could lead
to Too Much catastrophe so this hexing
tribe sealed the mask away in the
shadows interestingly in the original
Japanese version of the game the happy
mask salesman says that the original
tribe was destroyed and that there was
in fact a Calamity brought about by
majuta's mask and that quote our
ancestors sealed it away our ancestors
as in his and Link's shared ancestors
which would be the hylians themselves it
doesn't necessarily prove much but it is
interesting to think about and unknown
amount of time passes and eventually the
happy mask salesman gets his own hands
on the mask although we don't know how
or when or even why he knew about the
mask in the first place regardless the
Skull Kid eventually steals the mask
from him and cue the events of the game
the skull kid then begins to undergo an
evolution from harmless prankster to
more serious prankster to then taking
actual serious advances in his revenge
plot and decides to trap his old friends
inside the giant masks curse the land
with numerous ailments and finally bring
the moon crashing into the face of the
Earth in order to destroy the world in
defiance of the festival that celebrates
the Sun and the Moon things so far are
ultimately pretty easy to understand kid
puts on Mass gets corrupted by mask
until the dark encounter with the Skull
Kid Atop The Clock Tower see once the
skull kid's plot is stopped by way of
the Giants literally holding the moon in
place Majora's Mask detaches from the
skull kid and proves for the first time
that it is sentient and this is where
stuff gets super interesting it then
proceeds to call the Skull Kid a puppet
and enters the moon itself empowering it
even more and continuing its downward
descent to destroy the world but wait
you might be thinking I thought that was
the skull kid's Revenge plan why does
Majora who may have been created by
ancient hylians want to destroy termina
what does termina have to do with
Majora's Mask the only thing that ties
Majora's Mask to termina and the Giants
is the skull kid himself so here's my
theory and of course you're welcome to
believe whichever one you'd like now I
have two theories one of which is the
literal theory of what's Happening here
within the lore of the universe and the
other of which is the theory of the
symbolism behind all of this and how it
makes sense on a meta scale but let's
start with the lore Theory when link
enters the moon personally I feel like
he enters the mind of Majora I mean a
limitless grassy field with a tree in it
being inside the Moon is probably
metaphysical you know probably there are
also children running around wearing the
four giant masks with one sitting alone
wearing Majora's Mask itself but the
reason why the mind of Majora is so
lonely feeling and the child wearing
Majora's Mask sits by themselves with
nobody to play with is because that is a
reflection of exactly what happened to
the skull kid it's what was in inside
the skull kid's heart and memories and
because the Skull Kid felt it Majora now
feels it that's why the four giant mask
children are free to play amongst
themselves while the Skull Kid slash
Majora child sits alone it's a perfect
picture of terminus history told from
the perspective of the skull kid but
this fictional reality also shares the
memories of Majora that's why the kids
look like the happy mask salesman and
why they ask link if he'll be a happy
mask salesman too since Majora remembers
the happy mask salesman as the only
individual in the past countless amount
of years to pay attention to it
according to the old Miiverse website
that again has since been taken down the
happy mask salesman himself says that
he's never met these children before and
that he doesn't think they're normal
kids and that he's pretty sure there's
some figment created by the Majora's
Mask he even recognizes that they have
the same hairstyle as him so young yet
so stylish but now we're left wondering
everything in this grassy field all of
the dialogue from these children their
appearances The Masks it all stems from
either the memories of the skull kid or
the Majora's Mask itself but why AI well
I believe it's because of the fact that
Majora's Mask is now alive but let me
explain see the Majora's Mask when
Warren gives the use of the power to
make their wishes a reality much like
the Triforce actually but yet the
opposite of it see the Triforce will
grant the wish of its user but will
separate if its user is unbalanced
meaning the Triforce requires balance
Majora's Mask on the other hand creates
imbalance it corrupts it takes the
deepest darkest Parts within your mind
and brings them to the surface
eventually making those dark thoughts
worsen and completely take control think
about it like the Venom symbiote and
Spider-Man but if the Venom symbiote
also granted the wishes of Spider-Man
now give that symbiote to an angry
emotionally distraught human being who
has not yet figured out how to control
their emotions like a child or a skull
kid that in and of itself is a scary
notion but I think that the true horror
is actually even worse see there's a
reason why Majora's Mask initially
wasn't alive but it is now and why it
was so terrifying to the ancient tribe
once they discovered its true nature in
my opinion Majora's Mask dark the
wearer's heart because it feeds off of
it it grows from it and eventually it
becomes alive because of it and forms a
literal incarnation of the darkness of
its wearer's heart their darkest desires
their deepest hurts their inescapable
loneliness and the culmination of all of
their wrath and that is the
heartbreaking deep dark horror of
Majora's Mask it's why Majora pushed the
dark thoughts and feelings within the
skull kid to the surface it's why Majora
continued to enter the moon and pursue
the same dark intentions given to it
from the skull kid it's why the moon
Area created by Majora is lonely and
desolate and it's why Majora itself is
wild and childish and full of Wrath like
the skull kid and begins forming a veiny
organic body based off of these very
emotions in front of our eyes and we
know this is the entire darkness of
Majora because after defeating it the
evil has officially escaped The Mask
proven by the happy mask salesman but
one other aspect of the final fight that
I don't have to explain but I will
anyway because according to the Hyrule
Historia is the canonical version of
events would be the fierce deity's mask
that link Dawns in order to transform
into the fierce deity and kill Majora's
Mask once and for all the Japanese term
for it is kishin which is used to refer
to gods that have a righteous Theory
against the enemies of humanity and
according to aonuma himself the fierce
deity mask is supposed to be the
culmination of all the memories of
terminus people their combined will if
you will it seems to me that just like
Majora's Mask is the Incarnation of
Darkness of the skull kid's heart the
fierce deity is the Incarnation of the
righteous Fury of humanity now it's
given to link from inside the Majora
moon Area from the child representing
Majora itself so that they can play good
cop bad cop before fighting which is
strange but makes more sense when you
look at the situation symbolically and
to explain the symbolism let's start
again with Majora's Mask The Deadly
heart-shaped ancient hexing mask is a
picture of what happens if the dark and
harmful will towards others inside our
hearts is left unchecked specifically
with a focus on how angry and wrathful
we can be in our childhood when our
emotions have yet to mature and the
masks that link gives to the Moon
children that run around wanting nothing
but to play games represents the
different pieces of our childhoods our
imaginations the games we would play and
when you give the final piece of your
immaturity away you receive the more
grim and serious maturity of adulthood
in return which has the power to destroy
even the darkest of childhood intentions
or hurts because after all isn't the
skull kid's wrath warranted wasn't he
hurt by the Giants his closest friends
the problem is he went too far and
wasn't mature enough to deal with it so
simply put Majora's Mask to me among
many things is an allegory for growing
up and overcoming and defeating the
traumas of our childhood the darkness we
so often bring with us but that's just
my thoughts on the matter a Zelda game
without bosses is like a soda vending
machine that only sells club soda you
know that flavorless sparkling water
which is gross I hate drinking that
stuff I'd much rather have a Fanta or a
Sprite or a Diet Coke the simplest way
to go about explaining wind waker's many
bosses and minibosses would be to just
go in order of the games dungeon so
we're gonna do just that starting with
the very first dungeon in the game
dragon Roost Cavern located on Dragon
Roost Isle the very first mini boss you
face is a moblin and actually
technically you face up a coblin as a
minibus before the moblin way back in
the Forsaken Fortress both of these
enemies are just regular monsters
stemming from Hyrule which may or may
not have originated entirely from
demise's demonic power many years ago
depending on what you believe but in the
Wind Waker the only thing that really
needs explaining is how they're here and
by here I mean up here as in on the
surface of the ocean and not down in
Hyrule where they came from fortunately
for us the answer is rather simple
Ganondorf himself brought these monsters
up from Deep beneath the waves when he
began to execute his plan of regaining
the pieces of the Triforce having it
ripped from his clutches All Those Years
Ago by the hero of time in Princess
Zelda but more on ganondorf's story
later in the video the boss of dragon
Roost Cavern is a giant totally not
nightmare inducing arachnid centipede
Lava Monster insect thing known as Goma
now according to a direct quote from the
wind waker's great Deku Tree the
monsters that stir in the Forbidden
Woods are there because of ganondorf's
return and the same reasoning can
probably be used to blanket explain a
lot of the monsters appearances in the
game including the likes of Goma herself
while that may seem like an adequate
explanation I wouldn't make these videos
if I didn't think I could bring
something else to the table and in this
case I'd like to mention that I think
what Ganondorf did specifically is he
simply introduced one of the magtail
monsters into the cavern at some point
which then grew into Goma which then
began to lay eggs and give birth to
other magtails and spread them
throughout the dungeon I mean Goma
really does seem like a big version of
the smaller magtail monster with being
centipede-like immune to Lava having a
single eye and giant pincers and all
that who knows maybe there even would
have been several gomas if link hadn't
obliterated these ones next up we have
the formerly mentioned Forbidden Woods
located right next to the rather
friendly and not Forbidden Forest Haven
now I'm not gonna go super in depth into
explaining the dungeon itself and why
it's separate from the Forest Haven
proper and why I think it very closely
resembles the forest Haven because I'm
probably going to start up a series on
the lore of the dungeons here pretty
soon so I'm gonna skip straight to the
bosses the mini boss of the dungeon is
once again an insect monster known as
mafula which comes in two versions
winged and non-winged though I
personally assume that the winged
version is the fully mature version just
like all the other mini bosses in the
game Mafia itself is not very one of a
kind in fact there are many of them in
the game across various little caves and
such and they actually make appearances
in other Zelda games such as a link to
the past where they appear in the Skull
Woods which is the Dark World variant of
the Lost Woods coincidence I think not
what mafules are is a very dangerous
species of mutant moth that can spurt
out little babies called morphs that are
little one-eyed spiky balls that love to
latch onto moving organisms like link
and just kind of sit there slowing you
down they don't want to eat you or
anything they just invade your personal
space which is rude the morphs
themselves are present all over the
place in the Forbidden Woods which leads
me to believe that Ganondorf did a very
similar thing here like he did with the
magtails in Dragon Roost Cavern just
released an infestation of moreths to
take over the place lots of fun the main
boss of the Forbidden Woods is a bit
more abstract to explain in that it's a
living killer plant known as the kale
demos and seeing as the theme of the
entire dungeon is overgrown killer
nature it makes sense to me that the
kalai demos would be an overgrown more
deadly version of a bokobaba of which
there are several present here in the
Forbidden Woods and even on the Forest
Haven it's so massive that it uses its
roots as weapons and Vines to literally
detach from the ground and theoretically
be able to move all around the place if
it wanted to hacking could probably
vacation on Windfall Island as far as
what its name means it's unsure since
the original Japanese name for the kalei
demos is Kare demos so there really
aren't any hints there but in the
Spanish version of the game its name is
villopendulia which if translated in
Latin means to blaspheme or to revile or
if translated in Corsican means
vilification which is kind of the same
thing following up on this name meaning
it could be interpreted that it relates
to the Forbidden Woods directly since
the Forbidden wood itself is more than
likely the corrupted version of the old
Lost Woods but more on that in the
probable upcoming dungeon video the
kalai demos can also be killed
immediately with the forest water from
the Deku Tree so the corruption Theory
kind of makes sense as far as what led
to this monster plant becoming a monster
plant it can be assumed that it was due
to the same curse placed upon the Woods
by Ganondorf that led to all the
overgrown Vines around the place and of
course the wonderful moths and mafila
moving on next up we have the bosses
from the Tower of the Gods which
alternatively actually is not an area
that was corrupted or infested with evil
or anything of the sort actually quite
the opposite the Tower of the Gods and
its enemies within were all created by
certain people in the past you know kind
of like all the sheikah shrines in
breath of the wild the minibus of the
tower is the very first Dark Knight you
face in the game and the reason why I
say the first Dark Knight is because
there are many many dark nuts in other
locations throughout this game this one
specifically however is if it's special
because it's located within the mostly
untouched Tower of the Gods thus giving
even more credence to an older theory of
mind about the dark notes and their
literal possible blood relations to link
which I will link in the description
below if you're interested in a much
deeper dive for the time being however
it's my interpretation that the dark
nuts are actually corrupted old Knights
of Hyrule after all every single one of
them in the Wind Waker wears a knight's
Crest which has pretty obvious loftwing
symbolism on it and as a reminder
loftwings are the symbol of the
Hollywood royal family and I highly
doubt that every single one of the dark
notes would be able to steal a knight's
Crest I believe this particular dark
note was placed here to test to the hero
like all the other various enemies and
mechanisms in the Tower of the Gods but
that it was tainted by ganondorf's Magic
due to other reasons that I go into in
the aforementioned video the boss of the
dungeon is a grand combat construct that
snorts arrows known as godan the great
Arbiter godan's figurine describes it as
a construct that was placed there
directly by the gods themselves in order
to test the hero's combat Pro s and this
is pretty much entirely accurate
actually it is a tester and its title
The Great Arbiter literally means the
great decider as in it decides whether
or not the hero is worthy it's pretty
cut and dry and the only question
remaining is whether or not the gods
themselves actually literally crafted
godan with their own hands or if they
tasked certain other people to do so in
their stead personally my money's on the
sheikah I mean come on with all the eye
symbolism everywhere the grand ancient
technology the servitude to the gods and
the neon blue energy yeah it all seems
to fit the criteria moving on the next
dungeon that link has to fight through
is actually a return to the Forsaken
Fortress now that he's descended down to
Old Hyrule and retrieved the master
sword from its secret chamber of the
sages the first boss that link faces is
the mini boss known as Phantom Ganon and
this should be a familiar enemy for many
fans of the series because Phantom Ganon
made his debut in the previous game in
the timeline Ocarina of Time where in
that game Phantom Ganon is heavily
implied to be a separate living demonic
being created by Ganondorf via his dark
powers in order to fight Link after
which he gets banished to the quote gap
between Dimensions which probably means
nothingness in a spooky Cosmic of crafty
and kind of way the Phantom ganons In
The Wind Waker are largely the same they
are Phantom versions of Ganondorf
himself that he sends out to try to
commit murder upon link they even use
the same Dead Man's volley move set to
attack link one thing you might be
wondering though is why did Ganondorf
not send out a phantom Ganon or two to
protect the Forsaken Fortress the first
time around and this is actually because
of Link see as Ganondorf himself proves
to us when link drew the master sword it
actually released the seal on
ganondorf's power previously I guess he
was just running on fumes but with his
true Powers restored he's able to
construct an unlimited number of these
Phantoms to fight against link and by
the way if you're interested in why the
master sword was able to seal
ganondorf's power and also all of the
kingdom of Hyrule in stasis and why it
looks so different and why its
positioned somewhere completely
different to its last location in
Ocarina of Time check out this Theory I
did on the possibility of a second
master sword you're gonna love it it's
really neat actually and one last thing
I'll mention about the Phantom ganon's
in Wind Waker is that their swords
actually Bear an inscription on the
blade Aid the inscription reads zubora
gabora when read in Hylian which are the
names of the two smithies in the
Mountain Village in Majora's Mask yeah
there's probably a theory or 12 there
but we don't have time for that so
anyway the actual Boss Of The Forsaken
Fortress this time around is that big
gnarly nasty giant child kidnapping bird
known as the Monstrous helmerok King the
bird looks very very similar to the car
Crux in the game in fact they have
nearly identical feather patterns on
their bodies and wings nearly identical
feet and the helmerok's tail looks like
a more grander and duplicated version of
the cargurox this pretty heavily implies
that the helmerok is an overgrown
version of a cargo Rock maybe this is
what happens when you actually eat all
of your veggies growing up I guess Mom
was on to something now it is possible
that the helmerok is so massive due to
ganondorf's influence or power or
corruption but I personally find that a
bit difficult to believe since his
powers were much weaker prior to Link's
removal of the master sword meaning the
greater chance is that the helmerok is
really just a big cargo Rock I also
wanted to mention that it shares both a
name and an extremely similar fight to
the Helma sore King from A Link to the
Past both of which actually shared the
same name in Japanese
link must use a mighty Hammer to break
both of their helmets before being able
to unleash punishment on their faces and
the helmishor king is also just a bigger
version of smaller helmosaurs which is
yet another similarity to the Helmer
Rock King helmosaurs make other
appearances in the child timeline in the
Fallen timeline but never do pop up in
the adult timeline perhaps this means
that the Wind Waker kargaruk species is
the evolution of the helmosaur species
which would fit into wind waker's
evolved Hyrule theme with other races
and monsters and cargo rocks and
Twilight Princess are very lizard-like
and since Twilight Princess takes place
sooner after Ocarina of Time than Wind
Waker does that could mean that these
cargo rocks are in their middle step on
their way to evolving into the ones we
see in the Wind Waker but I digress I
didn't really mean to go into cargox as
much but there you go the helm Rock King
explained the next dungeon that the
Brave Young green boy must Venture
through is the Earth Temple the first
boss of which is is a stealthos now
anyone who knows the Legend of Zelda
knows about stalfo's enemies simply put
estafos is a demonically resurrected
pile of bones could be anyone's bones
could be a humans or a lizolfo's or a
bakoblins or yours or mine that would be
gross but the stealthos and wind wakers
share explanations with all stealthos
enemies throughout the entire franchise
which is that they are resurrected
baddies that arise via the power of evil
which stems from Ganondorf which stems
from demise the main boss of the Earth
Temple is jalhala which is a large Poe
made of a conglomerate of smaller pose
if you watched my previous bossler video
on Twilight Princess you'll probably
recall that I stated that I believed
that the death sword from that game is
also a conglomeration of dead Spirits or
pose in this case you can literally
watch as multiple pose gather into the
mask of jalhala to form its giant bod
which pretty much immediately explains
everything well almost everything see
jalhala is actually very old ancient
even it was actually the being
responsible for murdering the previous
Sage of Earth named laruto medley's
predecessor and also the only Zora you
see in the game when you combine this
with the fact that it once again appears
as a mini boss alongside Goma the
kaleidemos and mulcera in ganon's Castle
it can be inferred that this means that
it or more specifically the mask that
forms its big bod was created by
Ganondorf perhaps he once again just
released a bunch of pose in The Mask
itself into the Earth Temple in order to
corrupt it like he's done several times
before In This Very video as a reminder
pose in this franchise are specifically
ill-spirited spirits that roam the land
of the living because they have
unfinished business and are filled with
negativity and thoughts of violence
combine a bunch of them into a big Poe
and you get gel holla the second to last
dungeon in the game is the wind Temple
the mini boss of the temple is a whiz
row which again is not a unique enemy
but it kind of is because it wears red
and it's also much more powerful than
the other lesser wisrobe and can even
summon other lesser Wiz robes to fight
for it which is kind of meta now as I
explained in the Majora's Mask boss lore
video wiz robes are recurring enemies
across the Zelda franchise stemming from
the original game of a variable power
level sometimes they're normal enemies
that you can fight a bunch of at a time
other times like in Majora's Mask or
Wind Waker they're powerful enough to
Merit mini boss battles all by
themselves another variable about them
is their appearance which shifts from
looking like a human witch to grew from
Despicable Me to an anthropomorphic
toucan in this game I personally believe
that all Wiz robes are simply members of
a race of individuals located somewhere
in Hyrule that Masters dark magic and
either due to that Mastery or due to
their own personal reasons decides to
serve the forces of Darkness who in this
case is Ganondorf what's most intriguing
about their appearance in Wind Waker is
their bird-like physical features such
as their toucan-like beaks or their
sleeves that look like wings or the fact
that they can hover in the air and fly
given that this was also the game that
introduced us to the Rito who are the
race of bird people that evolved from
the Zora it's only natural for people to
wonder about whether or not the Wiz
robes are members of the Rito as well
which could very well be the case
personally though I tend to think a bit
more simplistically to me it just seems
like the Wiz robes might have used their
magic and turned themselves into these
bird-like forms in order to achieve
flight which they can do in this game as
opposed to their earlier iterations
which could only teleport around the
place but it's true given their bird
characteristics which is conveniently in
the same game that introduced us to the
Rito they could be wizrobes that stem
from the Rito race there's no evidence
to prove definitively one way or the
other and the retail also pretty much
all have long sleeves that turn into
Wings also there are lesser Wizards that
appear in the Tower of the Gods as I
mentioned earlier all of the mechanisms
and constructs within the Tower of the
Gods were constructed by the will of the
Gods and for the purposes of testing
link so how then could Wiz robes be
located inside well it's evident that at
least some of ganon's power was able to
enter the tower since there are keys and
Bubbles and choo choos and lesser
wizrobes in a crazed Darkness located
within so I suppose it's possible that
Ganondorf was able to sneak in a couple
monsters I'm not sure when he would have
been able to do this but that's neither
here nor there the boss of the wind
Temple is a giant flying sand monster
known as mogera and just like jalhala in
the Earth Temple moguera is assumedly
responsible for the death of the wind
Sage named Fado makara's predecessor and
the only Kokiri you see in the game and
just to follow suit with the whole big
monster with small versions of big
monster Vibes that the entire game has
been giving off this whole time Bulgaria
can also release its little babies to
attack link affectionately referred to
as mogera larvae in The Legend of Zelda
series it seems that certain words or
phrases of words are often used to refer
to that type of enemy for instance a
baba is always a plant a blind is always
a humanoid usually pig-like monster a
stall is always an undead enemy a foes
is a nightlike enemy a rock is a bird
and a mole is a sand or worm-like
monster in this manner the mulguera
shares its sand swimming capabilities
with that of the molduga of breath of
the wild or the mole dorms from several
other games and due to its reappearance
in ganon's Tower and Fado directly
saying that he was attacked by Ganondorf
and the encyclopedia stating that
ganon's minions attack the temples it
can be assumed that moguera originated
from you guessed it Ganondorf himself
seriously it's like after his defeat at
the end of Ocarina of Time he just
thought to himself you know what I
should do this time around in order to
guarantee me a win insects giant insects
but speaking of the big man himself it's
finally his time to shine so without
further Ado let's talk about the man the
myth the undying Legend Ganondorf
dragmire ganon's Tower is the final
dungeon in the game and as such Ganon
himself is the final boss both of them
in fact see the first time you encounter
Ganondorf it's not actually Ganondorf
but is rather a Ganon now for a much
more in-depth explanation as to what I
believe Ganon is as opposed to Ganondorf
and to not be too redundant in these
videos check out the breath of the Wild
bossler video where I went into much
more detail explaining it in a nutshell
though I personally believe that
Ganondorf will transform into a Ganon
when Ganondorf is infused with a great
power source with vegan as in the
original anthropomorphic pig-like
monster Ganon being ganondorf's Triforce
of power transformation however if you
recall at this point in the timeline
that Ganon is dead thanks to the hero of
time and this is why vat Ganon does not
make an appearance in Wind Waker it's
also why Ganondorf himself does not
physically transform into a Ganon in
this game even though it kind of looks
like he does in reality though that's
just puppet Ganon who's being controlled
by Ganondorf who is awaiting link above
puppet ganon's chamber on top of the
tower my take on the matter and of
course you're always welcome to believe
whichever take you want is that puppet
Ganon is the big version if you will of
the Phantom ganons located elsewhere in
the game just you know to follow suit
with the aforementioned small version
and big version of monsters that this
game is so fond of using I believe that
the puppet Ganon is essentially the most
powerful version of phantom Ganon that
Ganondorf could create which again also
explains why Ganondorf himself does not
transform into puppet Ganon unlike in
Ocarina of Time and Twilight Princess
when he did literally transform into the
Triforce powered Ganon and the
twilight-powered dark Beast Ganon anyway
once link kills puppet Ganon with arrows
of light he then ascends to face
Ganondorf himself who has had his
Triforce of power this entire time
because he still retained it following
his ceiling away at the end of Ocarina
of Time huge props to Nintendo by the
way for leaving us with this
foreshadowing Cliffhanger way back in
1998. to be honest wind waker's version
of Ganondorf has got to be one of my
favorites if not my favorite because
this is a Ganondorf who learned patience
he learned how to wait and buyed his
time to build up scraps of power at
first and eventually break out of the
seal that he was placed in so many years
ago he's more solemn and mature than any
of his other iterations and does not
necessarily wish to bring unnecessary
harm to Link and Zelda he even goes so
far as to try to reassure link by saying
do not fear I will not kill you and he
says that he wishes to sever that which
binds them together so that he would not
have to keep fighting literal children
every few centuries he also gives more
insight into the reasoning behind his
usurper actions and Ocarina of Time in
Twilight Princess the reason why he so
badly craves hyrule's Throne is because
he's jealous Covetous the Gerudo desert
his home is a harsh environment that few
species can survive in the day it's
blisteringly hot and in the night it's
bone-chillingly frigid something that we
can see firsthand in breath of the wild
as the king of the Garuda women who
somehow lived in the desert he wanted
better for them he wanted the beautiful
landscapes and temperate climates in
Bountiful fields that the Winds of
Hyrule brought to the people of Hyrule
and thus he decided to conquer the royal
family and try to take it by force but
now that Hyrule is all but dead and his
people are gone we're left with one
final question why why is Ganondorf
still striving so hard to obtain the
Triforce so long after everyone is
vanished and the world has moved on well
that's actually the entire Point have
you ever felt nostalgic Ganondorf did he
never wanted to hurt people at least not
initially all he ever wanted was Hyrule
he had heard the legends of an
all-powerful Relic that could Grant the
wishes of its user and he always wanted
to use that wish to obtain Hyrule for
himself and his people but as close as
he came to the Triforce he never got to
make that wish so here after countless
years have gone by and the world has
moved on from the Old Kingdom beneath
the waves Ganondorf never forgot about
that land that he loved Hyrule and as he
finally pieced to the Triforce together
again he reached his hand into the sky
and cried out to the gods above to
resurrect Hyrule from its watery slumber
and give it to him but just before he
touches the omnipotent Relic daphnis
nahants and Hyrule himself the last king
of Hyrule Touches at first and instead
wishes for the opposite that the world
would finally forget about the sins of
the Kingdom the crimes of the Gerudo and
the entire land of Hyrule itself be
drowned forever in Ganondorf along with
it and after all this time as the ocean
begins to literally crash in over their
heads with a great downpour of rain
Ganondorf cannot help but laugh in his
utter bitter defeat and it's at this
point that he lets his old angry self
shine through again and he decides to
try to kill link Zelda and the King but
is once again defeated for the Last Time
by The Duo of hylia's descendant and her
chosen hero the last thing Ganondorf
feels before entering the gap between
Dimensions himself is the Blissful wind
of the beautiful kingdom of Hyrule a
Zelda game without bosses is like a bowl
of ramen with only noodles it's like
wait what you've heard this intro before
oh I see I used it in the last video
okay let me do something new a Zelda
game without bosses is like beef stew
with only beef in it there a completely
new intro to start we're gonna go over
all of the bosses in the game that were
made through the power of the fused
Shadow which would Encompass the first
three diababa from the Forest Temple
virus from the Goron mines and more fuel
from the lake bed Temple Each of which
are pretty easy to explain as a reminder
or in case you've never played the game
the three main light spirits in the game
were responsible for sealing away the
powerful dark magic that The Interlopers
created in order to spite the gods see
the goddesses themselves weren't the
biggest fans of this idea so they had
the Light Spirit seal the magic away in
the fused Shadow relics which were then
each hidden within the aforementioned
temples except for the one that midno
wears on her head she just kind of has
that one when we meet her which she got
at some point after being turned into an
imp we don't really know where she got
it maybe The Interlopers took one with
them when they were banished Through the
Mirror into the toilet room but hey at
least it's conveniently the perfect fit
for her imp sized Cranium anyway the
three fused Shadows that were placed
within the temples kind of ended up
corrupting whatever life forms they came
in contact with which is what fused
Shadows do according to lederu since
they're essentially made of dark magic
the first boss in the game dayababa is
actually just a Deku Baba you know one
of these plants these really annoying
plants it's clear from the giant
decubaba heads and the name Baba in Daya
Baba that it was indeed a corrupted Deku
Baba and now I've said Deku Baba too
many times and it doesn't sound real
moving on virus from the Goron mines is
actually the patriarch of the gorons who
had entered the mine in order to figure
out why the volcano was acting so weird
Darvis apparently came into contact with
the fused Shadow once entering the
volcano and boom evil transformation
fortunately links many stabs from his
sword didn't actually kill him it just
beat the evil out of him and he soon
returned to normal right after not
remembering anything of the affair the
boss of the water temple I mean the lake
bed Temple more feel is once again a
fused Shadow corrupted eel which is
evidenced by its eel-like appearance and
the word eel in its name morpheel and
it's not super hard to believe that an
eel was living underwater so we'll call
this one good next let's move on to a
very similar kind of boss in the game
those that were corrupted by the pieces
of the mirror of twilight instead of the
fused Shadow which happens after Zant
destroys the mirror to preemptively
prevent midna from crossing over to the
other side since he was only able to
break it into four pieces one of which
remained on the mirror frame he needed
some place to hide them so he pulled a
light spirit's move and hid each piece
within a temple or mansion on top of a
mountain and speaking of a mansion on
top of the mountain the snow peak ruins
is the location of the first boss
blizzetta blizzetta is really just a
little yeti lady named Yeta who lives
alone with her husband appropriately
named yeto and who really likes her
piece of the mirror of twilight so much
so that bam it corrupts her and turns
her into a monster and may have even
snapped her neck fortunately you only
really have to break the evil ice she
builds up around her leaving her body
unscathed after the fight and fit for
some husband and wife Lovin moving on
the next piece of the mirror is found in
the distant past of the Temple of Time
It's curious as to how Zant was able to
do this since the door of time doesn't
open in the game until link places the
master sword in its pedestal once again
something Zant would not have been able
to do but that's another theory for
another day the boss of the Temple of
time is the Twilight arachnid armagoma
who is literally just a giant tarantula
spider meaning the mirror Shard must
have corrupted a tarantula spider in
order to make armagoma and sprout an
evil eye on her back and we know it's a
her because she makes lots of babies
this boss definitely gets heated from
existence though and once sufficiently
sent to the afterlife as all spiders
should be procures the second mirror
Shard the final Shard can be found high
in the sky in the city in the sky
inhabited by the strange Ooka race of
little chicken people anyway these
little chicken people were being
harassed by a dragon sent by Zant named
argarok the Twilight Dragon whose Aunt
created by corrupting one of the regular
car garak bird dinosaur enemies with the
final Shard of the mirror I'm not sure
if Zant meant for argurak to immediately
begin terrorizing the Uka people in the
sky or if he simply went wanted to hide
a shard in the most mobile form he could
think of but either way link and midna
are able to locate and kill the Beastie
and thus reclaim the final mirror Shard
with the bosses made through both forms
of Twilight corruption out of the way
let's now shift our Focus to the bosses
that are just regular beings or monsters
in the world of Hyrule untainted by the
corruption of Twilight the first boss on
this list is the Caked Up baboon named
oog Who is the very first mini boss of
the game actually ook is the leader of
the tribe of monkeys that live in the
Faron Woods just outside ordona and is
normally just a regular funny monkey guy
until he got corrupted but no not by the
Twilight see ook somehow had a parasitic
bug latch onto his forehead which was
the reason he started to go insane in
the first place this parasitic bug has
designs that are similar to the goats of
aardon which my good buddy lanlon
historian astutely pointed out so it's
probably safe to say that this bug is
actually a natural parasite that just so
happened to latch onto ook maybe even
while the Cake Master was sleeping
either way once properly spanked ook
smashes into a nearby totem pole so hard
that it knocks the parasite off of his
head which ends up dying immediately
after detaching from its host kinda
makes it makes bad for mercilessly
destroying UK's ass when you could have
just knocked off the bug huh anyway next
up we have the Goron guard named Dan
Goro or as I like to call him Dan who we
meet in the Goron mines Dan's just a
good guy who's doing his job of
protecting the sacred treasure hidden
within the mines which is of course the
Hero's Bow Dan isn't really the
brightest though so instead of just
asking why link is there Dan jumps
straight to trying to murder him once
you dump Dan into the lava a couple
times Dan listens to your reasons for
being there and immediately goes back to
being friendly and lets you pass just an
ordinary Dan who jumped the gun a bit
too early next up we have the Deku Toad
from the lake bed Temple and honestly
this one is just as simple as its
wildlife of Hyrule that somehow made its
home in the temple underneath Lake hylia
and just so happened to move into the
room that just so happened to have the
claw shot inside it which the toad just
so happened to swallow I highly doubt
that there was some grand scheme from
the makers of the temple for the hero to
slice up a literal toad or rather the
Toad's tongue in order to regain the
same sacred claw shot from its stomach
acids yeah pretty sure this one's just
an accident of nature anyway weird
vomiting and fibic enemies aside next up
we have the familiar skull kid from The
Lost Woods I mean the sacred grove it's
my opinion that this is the very same
skull kid as the skull kid from Ocarina
of Time in Majora's Mask because he
knows saria's song which the hero of
time taught to a particular Skull Kid
hundreds of years ago plus skull kids
are Immortal so it's definitely possible
but of course it's also possible that
it's just a different Skull Kid since
there are an unknown number of them
living in the woods and they could have
just heard the song The Skull Kid is a
childlike Forest Spirit who loves games
and mischief and who in this case forces
link to play with him before allowing
link access to the area deep within the
woods with a temple of time and
therefore the master sword rest but he's
not really a bad guy he's just the
fantasy version of it's a prank bro next
up is the dark Hammer from the
mysterious snow peak ruins now this is
definitely one of the more obscure
bosses in the game but I personally
subscribe to the notion that since the
snow peak ruins itself has strong ties
to the royal family of Hyrule and since
there are many cages and other dark
camera suits my farmer present in the
ruins the dark Hammer must be the result
of some sort of experimental super
soldier that the royal family was trying
their best to procure it's not like they
haven't done some very similar very
shady War tactic things in the past
either case in point being the Shadow
Temple from Ocarina of Time and they do
also have some of their Knights use the
ball and chain weapon over in the Fallen
timeline also it does make sense that
this dark Hammer would simply be one of
many due to the sheer number of giant
three-fingered suits of armor present
throughout the ruins so adding this all
together it's my interpretation that the
dark camera that link fights in the game
is a fragment of the ruins's history
which is that there were experimental
super soldiers created possibly from the
Liz alfos or dinolfo's species and
stored Within the Ruins one of which was
still alive and sprung to life when link
tried to pass through this storage room
but of course this is all theoretical
and if you personally have a better
theory that you'd rather believe you are
more than welcome to believe that
instead but I will say if you're
interested in the subject and you want
to learn more Celtic has a very good
theory video that sums up what I'm
trying to talk about I'll link to it the
description below moving on though the
next on Twilight boss would be the very
similar dark nut which is another giant
armor-clad enemy that's even more
intelligent and even more humanoid than
the dark Hammer now I have an entire
in-depth theory on The Dark Knight
enemies in general and how they link to
both the hero of time and the hero of
Twilight which I will link in the
description below again if you are
interested in a deeper dive into this
concept but in a nutshell it is again my
interpretation that the Dark Knights are
none other than corrupted Knights of
Hyrule the biggest evidence being their
physical placements and the clear
loftwing symbology on not only their
Twilight Princess appearances but also
their wind wicker appearance where
they're shown to flat out own night's
crests which again features a prominent
loftwing symbol and heavily emphasizes a
knight so yeah in a nutshell dark nuts
are corrupted Knights of Hyrule but for
more info check out my theory from 2020
moving on the next natural boss in the
game is the aerophose which simply put
is another sword and shield wielding
humanoid lizard enemy just like the
lizophos and dinofos who are also
similarly named except the aerophos is
Airborne with wings making them more
deadly and therefore more rare and also
like the little foes and Dino foes the
arrow foes serves the forces of evil
it's a long-running theory that all of
these lizard enemies are nothing more
than the creations of malice since
they're shown to be made of malice in
breath of the wild which would
technically mean that they come from
demise and are actually demons but
that's a separate theory for the
purposes of this video the aerofos is
just another evil serving lizard monster
that seems to be guarding the second
claw shot the first time we see it in
the game perhaps trying to prevent the
hero from obtaining the necessary item
to complete the city in the sky dungeon
and therefore claim the final mirror
Shard and finally it's time to talk
about the most recurring boss in the
game king boblin or as I like to call
him Zelda Shrek this guy's existence and
purpose is described by his name he's
the king of the Baldwin species of
monsters and he even explains why he and
his people are so actively trying to
kill you of their own volition he
follows the strongest side simply put he
must have witnessed the power of Zant at
some point in the game and decided that
for the health and well-being of he and
his people if he wanted to survive he
should probably be on Zant's side but
after witnessing Link in his powerful
ABS decided to switch sides to the good
side nobody likes a bandwagoner but hey
at least he's honest the bigger question
here is where do the Baldwin species
originate from in the first place since
they've rarely made appearances outside
this game but personally I don't think
this matters much especially since they
also make an appearance in the adult
timeline in the game's Spirit Tracks
meaning they're out there in the world
of Hyrule and Beyond we just don't see
them very often some people believe that
the bulbens are none other than the
evolved Garuda women but uh yeah no I I
don't buy that personally especially
because according to the encyclopedia
the Gerudo had actually moved further
into the desert at this point explaining
their absence the Baldwins must have
just bit another species of monster just
like bakoblins or moblins or lionels or
you know all the other species of
monsters in the series oh and King
Baldwin's Mount also has a name Lord
bulbo Lord of all bull bows which are
the giant pig monsters that Baldwins
ride on and that's about it the last
natural boss we'll discuss before moving
on to the main character bosses is the
one the only the Twilight bloat this
gorgeous elegant creature has many
similarities to a queen termite another
gorgeous elegant creature their beauty
is beyond compare and just like the
termite I believe the Twilight bloat is
the mother of all the shadow insects
their Queen if you will which were
created by Zant in order to steal the
light Spirits as tears of Twilight what
a beautiful animal species now with all
the non-main character bosses out of the
way it's time to focus on the two that
started it all Zant and the big man
Ganondorf himself but let's start with
Zant ant with a z had a job before he
usurped the Twilight throne in the
Twilight royal castle he was a helper of
the Twilight royal family who served
them because he believed that he would
be the next appointed to rule however to
his dismay when it came time to choose
the next leader it was midna who was
chosen instead of Zant because people
could see that he lusted for power and
not much else and she was then given the
powers that only the ruler of the
Twilight can possess now it's unknown if
the Twilight had a Royal bloodline like
the Hylian royal family has which would
imply that if midna and Sant are both up
for the crown that they would both be
related or if it's simply the matter of
appointing the next Monarch regardless
of blood relation either way Zant got a
little perturbed at this since after all
he was patient and tried to wait his
turn and in his desperation while he was
literally throwing a temper tantrum on a
balcony he lifted his eyes and saw a God
and this God had a name Ganondorf
Ganondorf vested part of his power which
is a mixture of dark Gerudo magic
stemming from his mother twin rova and
that of the Triforce of power in Zant
giving Zant much more power than that of
the simple ruler of Twilight with this
new power he cursed midna to Forever
assume the implug form we see her in for
the majority of the game and then
transformed all the remaining Twilight
people into mindless beasts that only
serve him known as The Shadow beasts
after taking care of any potential
pushback from his fellow Twilight he
then set his sights on the world he
wished to conquer the light world with
ganondorf's power he crossed over into
Hyrule and then tasked King boblin to
locate the light Spirits in in order to
send Shadow beasts to their locations to
Snuff them out plunge the light into
Twilight and transfer the light Spirits
as Tears of Light to the shadow insects
in one Fell Swoop he then took the
remaining Shadow beasts and powerfully
assaulted Hyrule Castle itself and was
greeted with total surrender from the
Hylian ruler Princess Zelda however
eventually Zant remembered that he has
yet to possess the full power of the
ruler of Twilight and tracks Down
Lincoln midna of his own volition he
then asks midna who is the true ruler of
Twilight to join him most likely
implying that he would appreciate it if
she would add her power to his she
refuses this because he's hella creepy
and then Zan proceeds to thrust her into
the light World which for a being of
Twilight that can't exist in the light
is probably something that felt kind of
like a fish being forced to swim in lava
of course Zelda saves mid in his life by
sacrificing her Essence and meanwhile
zand heads off to the arbit his grounds
to try to break apart the mirror and
prevent the heroic Duo from hunting him
down he even makes an appearance right
before Lincoln midna head up to the
mirror chamber and revives an ancient
stall enemy as a boss oh what's that you
notice I haven't covered Stallard yet
keep watching I'll get to him anyway
after which Zan proceeds to seemingly
Retreat back to the Twilight castle in
the realm of Twilight which ends up
being the very place that he would meet
his end after piecing together the
mirror of twilight link and midna then
enter the Twilight realm and kill Zant
once and for all but not before he was
able to confess to them the true origin
of his powers enter Ganondorf now if
you've been a Zelda fan for a while or
if you've watched my previous Boss video
you know why gandorf Rose to power and
all the lore surrounding his reasons so
I'll skip over his origin story for now
however I will explain what I think
happened to him after link was sent back
in time at the end of Ocarina of Time
see most people know that Ganondorf was
captured and his plans were prevented
but there's a bit more to that story
once Ganondorf was captured he wasn't
sentenced to death immediately according
to onuma his execution at the arbiter's
grounds happened several years after the
events of Ocarina of Time since we can
assume that link warned Zelda and the
Hylian royal family of ganondorf's true
intentions pretty much immediately
following his being sent back in time
which would have directly led to
ganondorf's capture this means that
Ganondorf was most likely imprisoned for
several years before his banishment
where was he imprisoned you ask why at
the arbiter's grounds of course now this
is where things get interesting because
the arbiter's grounds was according to
aoru or aru have you say his name the
site where the worst criminals in the
land were held and executed filling the
grounds themselves with their malice now
aru also says that the people who were
sentenced to be executed were instead
sent directly to the underworld aka the
realm of Twilight via the mirror of
twilight but we can tell this is only
half true because those who were
banished were specifically only the
ancient Interlopers as described by
lanairu but that was a long long time
ago there also just happens to be dead
bodies and pose present everywhere
within the arbiter's grounds implying
pretty heavily that there were in fact
inmates who were actually killed here as
well with their malicious Souls haunting
the hallways to this day enter one of
the creepiest bosses in the game the
death blade it's my simplistic personal
interpretation that the deathblade is
literally the malice of the Dead that
aru speaks of Haunting the arbitous
grounds or at least some of it as long
long historian and I were researching
the blade itself was most likely the
execution blade that was responsible for
taking countless lives of prisoners
leading to the blade itself being
haunted by their combined evil Essences
this also explains why the blade is
being held down to the ground with robes
covered in what looks to be ohura seals
which are used in several religions such
as Shinto and Buddhism which are present
in Japan and believed to do several
things one of which is sealing Spirits
away on the ground surrounding the blade
is a giant summoning circle with runes
drawn on the inside and only when the
roads attaching the ofuda seals to the
sword are severed the death sword spirit
is released heavily implying that this
room and the blade itself are meant to
trap The Souls of the most malicious
dead inmates within the goat-like spear
that materializes to control the sword
is in my opinion the spirit that the
sword was harboring which is in and of
itself another combination of Poe
Spirits like Bongo Bongo from Ocarina of
Time however this was not the only way
that inmates were executed in the
arbiter's grounds have you ever thought
it was weird that the entire arbiter's
ground setup is built as a Coliseum see
I think this plays into the reasons why
arbiter's grounds has been condemned and
people are now forbidden to even travel
there because what's the point of a
Coliseum combat that normally ends in
merciless gruesome deaths for slaves or
prisoners what if the big dark secret of
the arbiter's grounds isn't just that
there's a goddess ordained banishing
Relic held there or even that idmates
used to be executed there but that the
worst Prisoners the ones who Hyrule
hated the most were sentenced to a
gruesome death by combat against an
insurmountable foe in the midst of the
Coliseum enter starlord the Twilight
fossil now again just like several other
bosses in this video this is just my
theory and you're more than welcome to
believe whichever one you want lots of
fans of the series get caught up trying
to figure out who stalord is as in
whether or not Stallard is related to
volvagia or perhaps King dadongo for
Ocarina of Time since they're dinosaurs
and they all share the same boss fight
theme however I personally feel that
this line of thinking is impossible
because this is all assuming that
Stallard is somehow younger than the
aforementioned lizard bosses simply
because Twilight Princess takes place
after Ocarina of Time when all signs
point to the contrary since how Numa
states that Twilight Princess takes
place somewhere between 100 and 200
years after Ocarina of Time and
arbiter's grounds is clearly an ancient
rundown Coliseum that alone implies age
of potentially thousands of years not
one or two hundred given this and the
sheer size of the Colossal Star-Lord
himself and the fact that he was alive
long enough to grow that big and then
dead long enough to completely decompose
I'd wager that stalord himself is as
ancient if not more ancient than the
arbiter's grounds Coliseum itself
meaning the question isn't really
whether Star-Lord is or is a descendant
of volvagia or the dodongos but rather
whether they are the descendants of
Star-Lord but aside from who Star Lord
is isn't it strange that there's a giant
monster placed right in the middle of an
ancient desert Coliseum isn't it
possible that given the nature of giant
monsters and coliseums and the fact that
the arbiter's grounds was the location
where many prisoners were killed build
that Star-Lord himself was used as an
execution method for whoever was in
prison there as in Star-Lord was
execution by combat think about it why
would Stallard be placed here in the
center of the grounds directly
underneath the mirror chamber as a guard
for the mirror I heavily doubt that
since starlord was long dead before Zant
Scimitar of Twilight brought him back to
life and how would Stallard have even
gotten moved inside here in the first
place perhaps the grounds were built for
and around Star-Lord himself perhaps
Star-Lord is the entire point of the
Coliseum and furthermore what's with all
the stall soldiers that Stallard can
raise up from the sand at will if you
notice they're all wearing armor but
it's very rudimentary and cheap looking
and not at all like the armor of the
soldiers of Hyrule so it can be assumed
that these non-hylian soldiers were
instead prisoners who were given cheap
equipment to feign the hope that they
could stand in combat against the
terrifying starlord and again as a
reminder this has actually happened in
human history see the history of
Gladiators and the coliseums and
Nintendo draws inspiration from history
time and time again for the Zelda games
the point I'm trying to make though is
that by the time Ganondorf was
imprisoned here within the grounds
prisoners were actually being executed
there either by way of the death sword
quickly or by combat via stalord's
Coliseum chamber and this is also why
the sages attempted to execute Ganondorf
before resorting to banishing him which
is heavily implied with this cutscene to
be something they only do as an absolute
Last Resort so here's a neat little what
if explanation theory for you what if
Ganondorf who was imprisoned for years
and sentenced to death was sentenced to
die at the hands of the monster stalord
and what if Ganondorf was actually the
one prisoner who was able to kill him
perhaps this is even why Ganondorf tells
ant to go resurrect stalord using
ganon's own power he knew where Star
Lord's corpse was because he was the one
who made him a corpse and this led to
the sages taking matters into their own
hands and freaking out a little bit
since Ganondorf killed the big bad
Star-Lord and deciding to execute
Ganondorf personally or you know at
least attempting to but as most people
know this was unsuccessful in Ganondorf
was able to kill the sage of the water
before ultimately being banished out of
the Sage's desperation into the Twilight
realm along with the very same sword of
the sages that was meant to end his life
and once banished within the Twilight
Ganondorf Ganondorf was left bodiness
Ganondorf was left bottomless but alive
and was able to rebuild and recharge his
power while waiting over 100 years for a
suitable host who would help him return
to his beloved Kingdom of Hyrule and
finally claim the throne he so
desperately desired once Zant was denied
the crown and showed his true childish
colors Ganondorf saw the potential for
Zant to be emotionally manipulated and
housed part of his power within Zant
telling him not only to conquer the
Twilight but to also conquer Hyrule
within the light world so that he
himself could return via Zan's new power
after Hyrule has already fallen and once
Ganondorf was able to return to the
light he headed straight for the throne
sealing it off with a powerful Triforce
enabled barrier once he arrived
abandoning his disciples Aunt to fall at
the hands of the Twilight Princess and
this this is where he awaited Link in
midna's arrival until the end of the
game when he and Link and midna and
Zelda wage an epic battle against one
another that starts in the throne room
and ends in Hyrule Field where link is
finally able to best him in one-on-one
combat using the skills passed down from
the hero shade who poetically was the
first hero to face the Gerudo King in
order to end Ganondorf once and for all
and at the end of his life when ganroof
once again called upon the power of the
Triforce of power to save him from Death
as it did once before with the sages
Zant strangely pops up on the screen and
cracks his own neck to the side which
seemingly directly results in
ganondorf's actual final death and for a
much more in-depth explanation as to why
Zant popped up here and how his neck
crack possibly ended ganondorf's life
check out the video I made on that exact
topic it'll be linked below along with
all the other theories a Zelda game
without bosses is like a pizza with only
cheese on it which some people like but
where's the meat where's the olives
where's the pineapple Mamma Mia to start
let's cover the Overworld bosses in the
game which admittedly count for like a
hundred and 7 of the 114 total bosses in
breath of the wild or a whopping 94
percent the biggest number of Overworld
bosses comes from two types of giant
monsters the hynx and the stone Talus
hynexes are actually recurring bosses in
the zeld franchise you may recognize
them from the previous iterations and A
Link to the Past links Awakening or Link
Between Worlds in every appearance
they're always giant cyclops-like
enemies although by far their biggest
appearance size wise has got to be in
breath of the wild where they appear to
be oh at least 30 feet tall or so
because hynixes are present in other
games just like the Goblins or moblins
or Liz alfos or even stalfos it can be
assumed that their Origins are similar
to any monster found across Hyrule which
either means that they're just a natural
species of being that just so happens to
be evil or that they were created by way
of the malice of demise which is a
decently widely believed Theory
insinuating that all monsters across the
world of Hyrule or at least the organic
ones are made of malice which originated
from demise should this be the case then
hynaxes are no different and have simply
been created by Calamity Ganon and just
like most of the other enemies
throughout the game their connection to
ganon's fiendish power according to the
compendium is what results in their
differing colors according to their
individual power levels a couple High
mixes are actually dead and come back to
life as the skeletal versions called
stalnoxes which is of course due to the
influence of ganon's power and most
likely shares an explanation with all
stall enemies spanning the entire
franchise the bigger question is why
Ganon doesn't just make all of his
monsters immortal like the stall
monsters you'd think that would be a
pretty big brain move who knows maybe
his evil power can only go so far moving
on the stone Talus bosses are quite
literally living rocks that you know try
to commit murder upon seeing link
because they're made of solid rock
they're extremely durable and take very
little damage unless you attack a
certain spot and this spot appears to be
their exposed brain or maybe even heart
on their central body piece which
normally looks like an ore deposit and
is pretty much the only feasible way to
kill one of these Rocky dudes they also
seem to operate like a hub where really
their little brain deposit is the actual
stone Talus itself and everything else
just kind of sticks on or hovers around
forming arms and legs due to Magic this
enables them to mix and match other
Stone types into their body allowing
them to literally hurl their gigantic
Stone Arms weighing multiple tons
through the air in order to crush your
tiny human skull then just suck some
more rocks out of the ground to create a
new arm like nothing ever happened or
make their entire bodies out of molten
rock or even Frozen Rock now we could
also just say that ganon's power makes
the stone Talus monsters come to life
which is probably true either way but
there does appear to be some strange
things going on with them and patterns
that we can pick up on that would lead
us to believe that there's more to this
picture with regards to how they work
for instance Stone Palace has appeared
to grow and mature over time this is
evidenced by the little bitty baby stone
taluses called pebblets that you find
throughout the land followed by the
stone Palace Junior and stone Telus
senior bosses it could be that stone
taluses are really just little nuclei
that grow as minerals settle around them
leading to them growing or maturing over
time which is how rocks are formed in
real life so this explanation would be
fitting but the the biggest question
about these Rock dudes is where did that
little nucleus come from is it a
creation of ganons because he was just
feeling artistic one day when he saw a
rock for a more thorough Theory check
out this one I did about the possibility
of stone Talus is actually coming from
outer space I'll link to it below and be
sure to bring your tin hat with you with
the hinoxes and stone taluses out of the
way let's move on to the molduga this is
the rarest kind of recurring boss in the
game and again reanimates when ganon's
power surges under the light of a Blood
Moon so again it could be assumed that
muldugas are Simply Creations of malice
on the other hand creatures heavily
resembling moldugas can be seen
throughout the franchise as well like
the mole dorms from Twilight Princess
which also swim through the sand or the
mulgera boss from the Wind Waker and yes
I will be doing a wind wicker video soon
so stay tuned however I would like to
present one other possible explanation
that ties the malice Theory into the
wildlife of breath of the wild and that
would be that moldugas could be malice
corrupted sand seals it would make sense
given the corruption that malice is
known for and the fact that moldugas
have horizontal Tails unlike all all of
the other worm-like mole enemies spread
throughout the franchise but of course
this is just my theory the biggest
molduga is the moldu king that shows up
in breath of the Wild's DLC but to be
honest that's probably just a bigger
sand seal moving on to the last World
boss in the game which the wiki doesn't
count as a boss but I absolutely do
enter the wonderful peace loving Lionel
that's a joke these things are allergic
to peace lionels have once again had
other appearances in the franchise first
appearing in the first game actually
which means that the centaur-like Lionel
as a concept in Zelda actually predates
the bakoblin which is one of Zelda's
most common enemies in my opinion
lionels have essentially the exact same
backstory slash possible explanations as
the hynexes do they are also biological
monsters that could have either just
been abound in the land of Hyrule or
created purely out of malice one thing
that's notable about them though is
their intelligence which is rather high
for a monster their weapons are forged
for metal like the Liz olfos they can
see through disguises and they equip
multiple different items like a bow and
arrow and sword and shield or spear or
large beat stick the fact that they
Forge weapons and there are many of them
Leeds many fans believe that there could
be camps or communities of lionels that
survive together and share resources
which would only make sense given that
other enemies in the game do the same
thing we never come across a Lionel camp
in game but perhaps we'll see some of
these groups in tears of the Kingdom as
terrifying as that would be with the
world bosses out of the way it's time to
move on to the unique bosses of the game
aside from the final boss Calamity Ganon
and unfortunately there are only two one
of which is locked behind DLC so really
there's only one in the base game yeah
breath of the wild definitely could have
capitalized on having more unique bosses
but anyway let's start with the one in
the base game the strong the Burley the
one the only Master Koga himself Top
Banana of the yiga clan the yiga clan as
most fans know are defectors of the
shika Clan and as such are the same race
of human beings and feature the same
white hair and red eyes as proven by the
ex-yega man we meet in game Dorian the
yiga clan has sworn off their sibling
shika clan in everything they stand for
which includes the Hylian royal family
and the Hylian deities because of this
they actually serve Ganon instead and
are both trying to hasten his
resurrection and scouring the land in
search of the hero link just in case he
happens to still be alive 100 years
later this command is said to have been
given directly from their leader and is
so ingrained in their brains that they
actually carry out their sworn Duty even
when their leader is taken out of the
picture Koga himself has been alive for
over 100 years according to the age of
Calamity and apparently is the de facto
leader of the yiga and in spite of his
lazy napping nature is actually the
earner of the utmost respect from them
due to his Mastery of secret combat
techniques he claims that his techniques
come from his father's mother's father
which could possibly insinuate that his
bloodline has ruled the yiga clan for
several Generations since the secret
combat techniques that earn him his
respect didn't originate from him and
that's about all we know about Coca
anyway moving on to the next unique boss
in the game monk Maz koshia Maz koshia
is one of the well over 100 chica monks
in the game present within the shrines
that were built over 10 000 years ago
the monks themselves appear to have
committed a process known as
sokushinbutsu which is the real-life
Buddhist art of self-mummification that
almost 20 Japanese shingon monks
actually managed to do between the years
of 1081 and 1903 however even a
mummified human body can only take so
many Millennia and as such all of the
monks in breath of the wild dissolve
into dust after their shrines are
completed well all except for one Maz
koshia is much more involved with link
than any of the other Shrine monks where
each of them designed their own
respective shrines and normally welcome
link and congratulate him upon
completing their shrines Mas koshiya
actually orchestrates and guides link
telepathically through the entire
Champions ballad questline which takes
place all over Hyrule once link finishes
the many many steps to finding and
completing the much larger final trial
Maz koshia actually proves that these
monks may have still been alive and that
their voices weren't just Echoes of the
past recordings but that they were
really talking to link and may have even
been able to not only move a little but
move a lot Maz koshia actually stands up
in straight up fights Link in what he
refers to as the final trial within the
final trial which is probably one of the
coolest moments in the game it's unknown
what Maz koshia's relationship was to
the other Shrine monks as in whether or
not he was their leader or something but
he definitely was the greatest of them
and I personally like believing that the
shrines and trials in general were all
his idea since he refers to his own as
the final trial a neat little piece of
gameplay and lore that connects the
shika and yiga together would be the
fact that you can drop a banana on the
ground for Maz koshia and he will uh do
this similarly you can drop a banana on
the ground for a yiga soldier and they
will act the same now like I said before
they really are of the same Race So this
banana Obsession seems to run in the
family if you will maskia's fighting
Sals are also interesting and allude to
some in-universe lore as well such as
his ability to summon the extremely
similar spiky balls that Koga does
implying that koga's super secret combat
technique is actually a chica one and
that Maz koshiya might even be related
to Coca since the technique apparently
runs in koga's family plus koshia and
Koga do actually sound pretty similar
perhaps he even is is koga's father's
mother's father I mean these sheikah
types do tend to live a long time maybe
the bananas are the secret to long life
anyway koshia can also duplicate himself
which is the exact same move that impa
can pull off in age of Calamity once
again alluding to chica combat prowess
other than his moves at trials and
potential relation to Koga though there
isn't much else to talk about regarding
monk Mas koshia so now we'll move on and
let his bones rest once and for all the
final boss slash bosses we're going to
cover in this video would be that of
Calamity Ganon himself I mean itself and
all of its goons for those who might be
unfamiliar Calamity Ganon is the latest
iteration of Ganon who originates from
Ganondorf more on him in my Ocarina of
Time and Twilight Princess and soon to
be wind walker boss videos though it is
said that by the time of breath of the
wild Ganon had been defeated and
resurrected Time After Time After Time
again so much so that his eventual
return is something that can be relied
upon prophetically but why is he able to
come back over and over where did
Calamity Ganon even come from great
question and the answer is in my opinion
from demise now buckle up because I'm
going to explain to you my purse theory
on the origins of Calamity Ganon and
Ganon in general which could differ from
your own you are of course free to
believe whichever you want but check
this out demise's Essence is sealed
within the master sword this much is a
fact proven by the ending of Skyward
Sword however before he Fades away he
promises that an incarnation of his
hatred will forever follow the bloodline
of hylia and the spirit of the hero all
the while laughing his ass off and kind
of having a jolly good time ask yourself
though what's so funny about losing a
battle to a teeny tiny little
insignificant human whelp it's not like
he was able to perform some ritual in
order to bring this curse of his into
life and no offense but that's kind of
poor storytelling if he's able to
literally curse the universe as we know
it by simply thinking it up in his brain
moments before literally being
eradicated from existence this franchise
is a big fan of rituals and Grandeur
happenings that precede major events or
changes in story so if demise who was so
cocky that he would win 20 minutes ago
gets his ass handed to him and is then
unable to perform a curse on hylia then
why is he laughing well I'll tell you
what I think I think demise had already
he cursed the world with his malice
think about it he was sealed away in the
giant imprisoned avocado for many years
ago by hylia herself yet monsters still
plagued the surface of early era Hyrule
and these Monsters Just So happen to be
created by Lois so clearly demise must
have released his mouth into the world
before he was ever imprisoned possibly
back in the age where he and hylia
battled directly and you know what
calamity Ganon is made of malice in its
purest form the culmination of all of
demise's hatred Unleashed upon the
universe in order to be a Scourge upon
hylia's bloodline epitomized into the
Mindless formless monster known as
Calamity Ganon but I hear you wondering
aloud but Bandit how did Ganondorf turn
into Ganon if Calamity Ganon comes from
malice which is separate from Ganondorf
well I'll tell you it's because I
believe that Calamity Ganon and regular
Ganon are two different monsters that's
right you heard me two different things
and for proof of this let's look at the
origin of Ganon canonically he was
created at this moment at the end of
Ocarina of Time When Ganondorf moments
from Death calls upon the power of the
Triforce of power to transform into a
hideous power hungry Pig Beast which is
then killed by Lincoln is never seen
again but band did I hear you wandering
aloud once more Gannon comes back in
other games yes yes he does but as
different ganons each time except for
the Ganon in the link to the past and
onward in this timeline he just Remains
the Same walking on two legs version of
Ganon since the Fallen timeline only
happens if Gannon kills link here at the
end but in Twilight Princess Ganondorf
once again transforms into a Ganon
referred to as dark Beast Ganon who has
a four-legged version created via the
power of the Twilight and is then killed
by Lincoln midna never to be seen again
in Wind Waker since Ganondorf retained
the Triforce of power following his
defeat at the hands of the hero of time
but since Ganon had been killed
previously in Ocarina of Time he instead
infuses a giant freaky transforming
puppet with his power and calls it
puppet Ganon now there are other
appearances of Ganon in the Fallen
timeline but it won't take the time to
go over each of them now my point is
that what if Ganon is the monster that
Ganondorf creates when infused with a
large extra Eternal source of power be
it the Triforce the Twilight or malice
see it's my opinion that due to seeing
ganondorf's corpse spewing mouths from
within in the tears of the Kingdom
trailers Calamity Ganon is the
culmination of demise's leftover malice
that has gotten a hold of Ganondorf and
used his body over and over and over
again over the countless Millennia to
create many different Calamity ganons
some of which even took different forms
and what's more is that perhaps the
malice appearing in tears of the Kingdom
right around the Ganon of corpse is more
tender-like and thick and deeply red in
color because it's bonded with
ganondorf's blood which resulted in his
drained appearance now the other
versions of Calamity Ganon called the
blight ganons which each take on the
abilities and moves of the Champions
they were responsible for killing 100
years ago are simply extensions of
Calamity Ganon itself since it's just
made of malice anyway and we know that
malice can clearly split apart as much
as it wants to across Hyrule and can
even create other monsters given that it
has bodies to corrupt and therefore
create other ganons should it have a
body like ganondorfs that's powerful
enough to corrupt and wouldn't you know
it we can't find the Champion's bodies
anywhere in the game and their blight
ganons each move just like they do but
for a much deeper dive into what I'm
insinuating here check out my video that
I did on that exact topic linked below
and that wraps up the complete 3D Zelda
boss lore video series thank you all so
much for being here and watching these
videos and contributing to the continued
success of the channel I wouldn't
continue making these videos if it
wasn't for you guys once again please
consider liking the video If you enjoyed
it or at least my efforts into making it
all and subscribe if you haven't already
for much much more huge thanks as always
to my Bandit crew who continually go
above and beyond in support of the
channel and a very warm welcome to Joy H
who just joined up that's all for this
one so be sure to follow me on my
socials and I'll see you next time this
is Bandit signing out
[Music]
thank you